You know when you're ready.
Yes.
Positive Energy.
You got it.
We're live,
ladies and gentlemen,
we're live on a day where a,
I saw a fucking mountain line on top of a telephone pole today.
Why not in real life?
Somebody said it to me on Twitter,
but it felt like I was there.
Have you fucking seen it?
Look at my,
on my Twitter,
Jamie,
there's a amount line.
It's stayed up on a telephone pole all day on Wednesday and then this morning it
came down but some s some screaming school kids,
friends of all school kids.
The idea that little kids could be so goddamn close to a murderous,
monstrous hundred 50 pound cat than it has to run up a pole.
And then the fact that it was up on that pole for an hour and a half and people
didn't have the good sense to a shooting.
Where was this ad isn't California?
Jesus?
What part of California?
Victorville.
Yeah.
You know,
that's like people live there.
Fuck that thing.
Oh my God,
look at its hanging out on top of a pole.
Like no big deal.
And I guess it's just going to climb down whether its claws imagined.
It's 150 pound animal that can climb trees with its claws.
Just runs up the top of that pole and sits up
where it's totally chill.
Just hanging.
There's no way for it to be electrocuted also cause there's no ground.
Is that why?
I don't know why that works.
Yeah.
I don't know how that works either.
It's like magic what?
Your foot's on the ground,
but yet that pulls on the ground.
It's always like don't touch the third rail.
Okay.
Well how's that work?
Is that just a,
was that just a rumor about the third rail on the railroad tracks?
I used to live on a railroad track pretty much as a kid.
We just played all day on railroad tracks,
put things in pennies,
got shot by the guys on the train.
They shot at you salt pellet guns.
Really?
Yeah.
Because you're not supposed to be on the train track and they like we would put
things on so they would just sit there and I think it was more just to scare you
but they would like shoot these like salt a bullets at you or something like
that.
A lot of people die by committing suicide of your train tracks.
Train tracks.
It's not,
that's not the third real.
The third rule is like subway stations.
It's not a train.
Train trucks are not electrical.
I mean the,
the uh,
the tracks just piece of metal.
Right.
The uh,
the real ones are the ones that are in subway somehow or another.
I don't know.
Like which ones are,
yeah,
cause that's actually electricity people have definitely died from that though.
They've definitely died from that I think.
Did you live by a train track growing up close enough?
I used to take the tea into Boston when I was a kid.
Like when I was in high school when we had a walk,
like,
like a mile or so.
It's sucked fucking hardcore in the winter though.
God Damn.
They're like,
when I think about winter today,
I think about the fact
that,
uh,
people in Boston are just about to go through it.
Like right now,
today's October 1st,
that means it's just going to start chilling out right now.
Now it's just going to start getting a little uncomfortable,
but not bad.
A little brisk,
not bad.
A little morning brisk get you a cup of coffee,
but there's a month where they're a month or two away from experiencing that
bone jarring cold that you only get in the northeast,
that wet,
wet ocean,
water cold.
Their world is different than our world,
man.
The world is different than our world.
When you go down there,
when you go to Boston,
you d do gigs up there in New Hampshire,
those are harder people.
They're just there.
They have to overcome way more shit.
Like the,
uh,
the stereotype of the California person,
like the slacker,
like you knew whatever dude,
it's new.
Big Deal Dude.
Like that's what people think of when they think of California.
It's cause we don't have to deal with that winter shit.
Yeah.
Well this one,
or we might be dealing without Nina Super El Nino is what they're saying that
we're going to get.
I mean,
it has been humid as fuck out here lately.
I hope to write we need it.
Yeah,
I mean I think,
isn't that how it always works?
Unless things,
I say it always works,
but unless things turn into deserts,
because deserts didn't always used to be deserts.
Like I think even at the Sahara at one point in time was like lush and that was
a,
that's the whole take on,
uh,
the,
the Sphinx,
like the,
the guys who want to backdate the Sphinx,
they've done these,
uh,
the Da brought in these geologists,
specifically this guy named Doctor Robert Schoch from Boston University and he
thinks that the water erosion on the,
the,
the container or the,
um,
uh,
the chamber,
the,
the temple,
this finks I think they're calling it and it's where they carve the sphinx out
of the ground.
The,
the whole temple area where the Sphinx is that there's these stones that are
carved,
that have all these water erosion marks all over them.
Like the deep fissures where water cuts through a crack and the and the rock and
does so for thousands of years.
So like this is like thousands of years of rainfall that's caused this water
erosion.
And the problem with that is the last time there was rainfall in the Nile Valley
was like 9,000 BC or 9,000 years ago,
I think it is.
So it's like 7,000 BC.
So that was like the last time there was rainfall there.
So it had been several thousand years before that of it raining on those rocks.
It create that kind of erosion before that place became a desert.
So that's the thing about California man,
it can easily become a desert.
Well,
there,
there was a,
uh,
it just sent your link.
Uh,
there was a cow,
a lake in California.
It's really popular.
I am in Westwood,
California.
Walter Lake the other day,
just overnight,
the whole lake drained out.
It emptied out there.
Was that,
that is true.
That's been proven.
Yeah.
It's a,
it's a saw that article and I thought,
well,
I don't know about this.
Is this real?
It was like one of those,
you know,
Bob's news reviews something?
Yeah.
It's got a website.
It was that Katie van actually went in there and re uh,
uh,
interviewed
them and there thousands of fish.
They say,
I don't know if you saw the photos,
it's just photos of tons of dead fish.
So what do they think happen?
Uh,
they pretty much just say we're out of water.
California lake disappears overnight.
Lee's behind thousands of fish.
Well that's like some Marky mark movie,
Apocalypse Shit.
Look at this.
There's a video right here.
Just that's fucked.
And this was like a,
I mean not,
this is not a small thing.
It's 170 acres.
A reservoir.
Wow.
170 acre reservoir,
which is overnight.
Yeah.
And where'd the water go?
It just went in the hole I think.
Yeah.
Look,
I think it went down,
but how could it go down that low?
That quick?
I don't understand.
I think that's pretty much reservoir runs dry.
Wow.
There's nothing there.
Look at all those fish.
That's fucked.
God,
this is terrible way to die for them.
Yeah.
And I guess they could have a,
they said if they had a note,
like a two week notice,
they could have taken all the fish and saved them and moved them to another lake
or something like that.
But well,
did they drain this on purpose?
No,
they just,
it just pretty much emptied out.
It's like,
it's kind of confusing how they say it,
but they pretty much just say that.
No,
we,
they just,
we just,
it's just out of water.
We're in a drought,
you know?
That's just how fast it happens.
So it literally can happen like that overnight.
Yeah.
I don't understand that.
And why doesn't,
It doesn't make any sense to me,
but it's a shallow ass fucking lake though.
He believes that may have occurred when a clogged outlet valve was cleared.
So literally the train was stuck.
They opened up the drain and now here's your reservoir going through a creek.
That's what,
that's what's going on,
right?
Yeah.
There's a lot of lakes like that in California and they could easily run dry
that lake Castaic.
That fucker is way smaller than it used to.
You said you've been there,
that's a,
is there a place?
It's the stay there that's I got,
cause I drove by it.
They recently
people all the camp there.
There's parts where you're allowed to camp.
Good fucking luck with that.
That's sketchy as fuck dude.
There's a lot of like there's places around lake a stick,
like a stag is real weird.
Like you get there and you're like,
are we in Guatemala?
Is this like a nomad?
Some sort of a food festival and Guatemala like this.
These people there that are just,
they,
you know,
families that like live in apartments especially they fucking love parks map.
They get those parks and they just take over.
They bring their family,
they lay out a giant blanket,
they start barbecue.
It's fucking great man.
It's really a,
it's actually a kind of a cool environment to,
for kids cause all these different kids,
different families,
they're all get together and there's music playing and people are cooking and
people from other countries they have more of,
for whatever reason they have more of this,
um,
this sort of inclination to have these gatherings and at least park gatherings,
it was pretty bad ass man.
Sometimes it's,
it's bad as other times it's like,
it's nonsense.
It's just like,
hey,
it's four 40 people to all get together wasted in a park where there's kids,
you know?
Yeah.
That can happen too.
Especially if it's been a hard road getting over here in America.
You're fucking struggling.
You've got some sort of a shitty job doing construction work under the table for
cash.
And now here you're at the party finally and you just getting lit screaming and
yelling,
dancing.
Did you see that concrete on the opposite side of droughts?
Uh,
the concrete that absorbs 880 gallons of water in a minute.
It's this concrete that they can now put on a roads and in parks.
And so,
so like places like Houston or Texas that you know,
you know,
these flash floods,
uh,
this is actually just absorbs water.
This is insane.
And we're looking at a video now for folks listening to this where there's a
giant water truck and the water truck is pouring water onto this parking lot and
the water just disappearing.
This is crazy.
It's on tech insider.com.
Yeah.
And I guess this technology has been around for a while.
They've just got it.
Oh Wow.
Good enough to actually use as concrete for cars,
how it works rather than you sand based concrete tarmac uses something called no
fines,
car concrete.
It's made of tiny pieces of crushed granite pack together while Burgess says the
mixture is extremely dry,
the pieces are packed loosely enough to allow water to pass through the system
can accommodate three designs,
full infiltration,
partial infiltration and full attenuation.
Wow.
That's fucking interesting man.
Wow,
that's smart.
Yeah.
Because like places like Houston,
like you said,
remember we were there,
um,
at this,
we used to work at this club there and we,
they would put us up in this,
uh,
who was the Allentown in what the fuck was the name?
Allen Town Parkway,
right?
Yeah.
And it was this like really fucking sketchy,
sketchy hotel.
They would put you up in where people would like knock on your door and asked
for crack.
Like literally there was this dude,
he was walking down the,
um,
the upper,
it wasn't a hallway was outside because it was like a pal can eat before he got
to the stairs cause it was a motel,
you know,
and uh,
the guys walking around the outside and he goes,
man,
who's a,
where's the head dude?
And I go,
I was like,
what?
He goes,
where's the head man?
And I'm like,
I dunno where Ed is that,
come on man.
You know where it is.
Where's that?
I'm like,
dude,
I don't fucking know where Ed is,
but it was just Jones in and he just looked at me and like,
this dude's a junkie.
He knows where the guy is.
Yeah.
I've been running into a lot of these junkies late,
like these meth heads.
They're just so out of it.
They don't,
they're not real people when they're on these drugs.
It's ridiculous.
You're pretty fucked up.
Yeah.
There was a,
a,
an article in one of the La magazines about,
I forget what it w which magazine,
but it was about how a lot of these poor communities in like south central La,
uh,
cocaine is like stupid expensive right now apparently.
But math is like way more common and so they're bringing meth in and because
everybody already has like the,
the people that we're bringing in weed before,
they can't make any money off a weed.
So now they've switched it to math and all these people are fucked up on math
and these like really shitty areas and shitty communities.
Cutting coke with math I guess is a thing.
Also now that people are doing cause coke so expensive.
So it's like you're,
you're buying coke,
but in that next thing you know you're our method.
Oh yeah.
You figure doing coke and getting meth.
I mean,
anybody could think that somehow or another we wouldn't.
It at least be helping people actually get whatever they,
they think they're getting by making this stuff legal.
Like the idea that a grown adult tells another grown adult that can't do cocaine
to me is mind boggling.
The fact that we have all this other stuff that you can do and you just
arbitrarily no cocaine.
Do you think p cocaine will ever become illegal?
It should totally be illegal.
It should be legal.
Yeah.
I think less people would do it.
I really do.
I think more people would be aware.
Look,
the alcohol's one of the most destructive to your body.
Destructive to society.
Destructive to your behavior and the kind of an eh kind of activities you engage
in drunk driving,
violent altercations,
drunk being drunk can be horrible.
It can wind up terrible and it's completely pervasive.
It's everywhere.
It's so prevalent.
It's in,
you can get booze and family,
restaurants.
You go to a family restaurant and get fucked up.
You know?
I mean you can,
you could get fucked up to the point where you fall asleep drive and you kill a
bunch of people,
100% you could do that.
You could get the drug of choice,
the most destructive drug at every cvs,
every pharmacy,
every supermarket,
every supermarket you go to,
you can get fucked up.
You go down that liquor aisle and you just grab bottles thrown in your cart.
You could drink them in the car and you would never be able to drive home like
instantly.
You'd be fucked.
And it's legal.
The idea that cocaine's not legal is silly.
I wouldn't do it.
I try it.
I think I would definitely try it.
I would try it just be,
if I knew it was absolute cocaine because like a Tom Sawyer from the punch line
in San Francisco from Cobbs,
remember Tom [inaudible],
he was always talking about rockstar cocaine.
Like I did rock star cocaine with Kennison and I'm like,
what's rockstar cocaine?
They,
he was talking about it like it was like someone talking about the days back
when Jesus was around.
It was like,
we would do it.
You'd be great.
And after it was over you just go to sleep.
And I was like,
what?
And he's like,
yeah,
it would wear off.
It wouldn't give you a hangover.
You'd just see like he was talking about like this fantasy land cocaine sounded
like nondestructive.
Not Bad for you.
Like oh we get a lot done.
I want to know how rock started cooking.
Cause cocaine is just makes you look more awake.
I mean,
so rock star cocaine just makes you even more awake or anything.
I think the idea is that the,
the,
the cocaine you're getting when you go to a regular place and you're partying,
uh,
is uh,
it's half speed or 20% speed or 5% speed or whatever the fuck it is.
It's,
it's stomped on.
It's cut up.
But the rockstar cocaine is pure cocaine.
And when you get pure cocaine,
this idea is that it's a better experience.
Yeah.
And most of the cocaine,
you just immediately are shitting every 10 minutes every time you do it.
Cause it's cut laxatives or will you smoke crack?
I found out I didn't smoke crack just the other day.
That's so funny you said that because I found out that what it was,
somebody was talking about free freebasing cocaine,
which is where you cook it with Baking Soda and you get the pure,
what you're doing is you're extracting the purity of the cocaine.
You're extracting the cocaine.
That's what I did.
It's the same thing.
Yeah,
that's what I said.
But I guess crack is a little bit more mixed with chemical,
some kind of hardening chemical or something like that.
I don't know.
Pretty sure.
It's the same thing.
And here's,
here's the real deal.
According to Dr. Carl Hart and one of the guys that I've talked to on occasion
who,
um,
he's a,
he's a drug expert.
He was only the bill O'Reilly show the other day.
Uh,
that's one of the reasons why I got in touch with him again.
I saw him on the bill O'Reilly show.
I'm like,
Dude,
how do you do that?
It was on it for like,
he made me,
he said like 30 seconds where the shit and the entire time it was on maybe talk
for like 15 seconds for someone interrupted them.
It's like one of those stupid shows which Jesus,
but anyway,
he was talking about how crazy it is that you get sentenced far more brutally if
you get caught with crack.
And uh,
like what,
what kind of jail time you're looking at weather versus getting caught with
cocaine.
And he's like,
it's totally racist because it's the same drug,
it's exact same drug.
He's like there's,
there's no difference whatsoever between the two.
Like the,
the experience,
the high,
like if you,
if you do one,
you do the other,
it's the same thing.
So the fact that one of them will get you like 10 year mandatory minimum and the
other one you're out in like six months or whatever the fuck it,
it would be if you're selling one of the other,
I wonder why,
how many it's cause you prepared it or something,
you know,
black people in jail,
it's because they want to
black people in jail.
Wait,
it's just,
it's just because they're selling it in these crime filled environments,
you know,
so it's whether or not it's racist or whether it's a response to the environment
in which they're selling crack.
The idea is if you go to the country club and you're teeing off with,
you know,
Brad at 4:00 PM,
uh,
you guys are going to do a little bump before you're,
you're not the guy who is selling crack out of the backseat of his,
uh,
hopped up Nissan and uh,
you know,
shooting at people and who knows what the fuck else he's doing kind of stupid
shit.
This guy's involved and he's creating a nuisance for the neighborhood.
That's the idea,
right?
I just wondered like legally how that they can make it a difference if it was
like,
oh,
well it weighs more or something.
You know what I mean?
Make
their own rules.
Dude.
Legal though the idea of what they can do and not do legally so fucked up
because one of the ways that bust pot dealers is way,
not just the pot,
but they way that the dirt and the pot that the pot is planted it,
right.
They way the whole thing,
they don't cut your trees down and say,
well,
let's see how much of the effective drug do we have here.
Because once you pull the buds out,
you're dealing with a fraction of the weight of the tree.
But these assholes,
they way the pebbles that are in the soil,
they weigh everything.
The water that you,
you know your water,
those plants,
they're in a pot,
the pots,
heavy,
tough shit for you.
It looks like you've got to fucking 50 pound pot plant and you're like,
what?
There's not even a pound of weed on that stupid plan,
but they'll,
they'll hit you for 50 and then they'll get you for like major possession,
major distribution to goddamn travesty.
The fact that this has been going on for so long too,
it's an to into our middle ages.
I mean,
you and I are both in our forties now and we're still living in this ridiculous
society that thinks it's okay to lock people in a cage because they decide they
want to do this.
I want to smoke this or I want to grow that.
I want to sell that.
You could sell tomatoes,
but don't sell weed.
Fuck you.
It's stupid.
We're grown adults.
You know,
the idea that we're going to go to the grave and the,
the world that we leave behind is going to be just as fucking stupid as it was
when we were in high school.
That's infuriating to me.
You know,
and I don't think that making cocaine,
legal or bunch of people doing cocaine is going to help anything.
I certainly don't think that,
but if it does help,
one thing,
it'll help people recognize what coke really is.
Like if you see someone who's fucked up that's a drunk,
like you got a church,
like I've seen people at bars,
I'm like,
I am not fucking drinking.
Like I don't want to be that guy.
You know?
And like he,
I think that's a big part of how people learn is watching people around us fuck
up and when no one around you fuck up fucks up.
That's when you have this sort of really distorted perception of what's going on
and having,
you know,
no real understanding of what the effects of cocaine are on a one to one basis.
If you saw it,
if you saw someone that you know doing it or if you did it,
you would know like right now it's,
it's got too much myth behind it.
You know,
it's part of the fucking Scarface thing.
like you're,
you're fucking,
I don't give a shit bro.
I'm doing coke and it's not just that you're doing this speedy drug.
It's also that you're being a bad boy or a bad girl doing that coke.
Well it is a lot of uh,
undressing all the shit we grew up on and feared and you know,
we,
we grew up thinking weed was the worst thing ever.
We,
you know,
same thing with you know,
cocaine and it is now that we have the internet and everything we write to add
our fingertips that we're learning like oh wait a second.
Cocaine is not even a schedule three drug or whatever it is scheduled to.
Yeah.
Cause that was medical uses.
Right.
Here's a fun fact about cocaine.
Coca Cola is made with cocaine.
Coca Cola was always made with cocaine back in the day and it had actual cocaine
in the coke.
Now part of flavor in Coca Cola
comes from the cocoa leaves.
So they take coca leaves,
they extract the cocaine and they use that cocaine from medical cocaine.
And then the rest,
like the flavoring,
some process goes into Coca Cola.
That's why coke rules and Pepsi drills
because it's got coconut.
That's hilarious.
They have coke in their name.
Pepsi can't take,
they can't take,
you know,
coke.
Even though coke is like universal,
like you can't own coke.
Like if someone,
like if cocaine became legal and Coca Cola was like,
we're making our own cocaine,
coke cook like you couldn't study,
couldn't stop anybody else from calling a coke because it's coke.
Like it's an established name for it.
It's like if somebody tried to a patent,
the word pot,
you know,
we'd be like,
get the fuck outta here.
You can't pat and pot stupid.
I just found there was another thing that was really weird.
It was like mountain dew or another soda that was,
uh,
also had like a weird history secret.
Like if it was mountain dew or it was at mountain dew.
Mountain dew is like moonshine.
Yeah,
it was moonshine.
It was moonshine made to mix with moonshine.
Yeah.
Oh,
it was designed to mix with my insurance.
It's a nickname mountain dew as his nickname and the
god,
that makes sense and that's why PDC drinks it every day with two.
That makes it all drone.
Here's how fucked up I am.
That makes me want a mountain dew.
It makes me want to mountain dew with some moonshine.
Oh,
all of a sudden.
That's like what I want to drink right now.
Let's shit with real sugar.
It's not too bad.
It tastes a little bit different than why don't we have mountain dew here and
having to throw it back when I need to get,
now let's get mountain dew and so we have some moonshine already.
Right?
You get the 300 mountains.
We have some fake ass moonshine.
No,
no.
Hillbilly made our moonshine.
We have the moonshine dish featured on the history channel.
Those fucking dudes.
Yeah.
If they sell,
if they sell the same moonshine at Applebee's,
you know it's not the real moon shine.
It's like this absence that we got.
It's not even absence.
We got like grapes,
cider or something.
The Applebee's.
Yeah,
we had real absence once.
Remember that in Vancouver it was fucked up.
That was weird.
I described it as like a cousin to drunk.
It wasn't quite like being drunk.
It was like being drunk cousin,
creepy drunk.
Very strange.
Like it didn't fuck me up.
I was,
it was,
it was uncomfortable because it was definitely different and I wasn't sure what
to expect,
but it wasn't bad.
I mean it's definitely a lot like drunk,
like I never drive on it.
You could definitely tell that you're,
you're hindered physically.
Like Yolo,
you will a little like you would make bad decisions,
but it wasn't a,
it was just,
it was definitely different though.
Wonder if I'm right.
I'm wondering if you could talk to,
well,
like a Dr. Carl Hart type guy.
He was like,
no,
it's all in your head.
It was basically just like being drunk.
Just what a shitty flavor.
Yeah.
I wonder half of it might be just like your myth.
They were,
but you think it is because I mean,
back in the day they used to say used to trip from drinking absence,
but nowadays you don't hear that anymore.
But maybe the not
getting the good stuff.
Yeah.
Right.
Really good at what the fuck is wormwood,
right.
That's what they use to make absence.
Right.
I don't know who I were.
Uninformed Paul this up Jay.
It's fine.
I had to put it over sugar cubes or something to activate some.
There's something like that,
but the stuff that we had,
yeah,
they did do it over sugar,
didn't they?
Yeah.
I forget how they did it and it tastes like licorice.
It was all long time ago.
Where was that?
Seattle.
No,
I believe that was Vancouver because it's legal up there.
That was the deal that it was up in Canada.
It's a confirmed that you're 21 years old.
Enter liquor.com.
Nice.
The five biggest absent myths.
Yeah.
So they're pouring it over this,
uh,
this sugar cube.
What's the myths?
And it's turning yellow.
Absinthe is hallucinating.
That's a myth.
Marketers love to capitalize on the products,
illicit reputation,
but the fact is it's no more likely to make you see things than vodka.
Whiskey or Tequila absence was banned because it's hallucinogenic.
That's also another meth.
If absence isn't hallucinogenic,
why was it banned in most European countries and in the u s and the early 20th
century absence became a victim of its own popularity when the French wine
industry and temperance movement targeted a common scape goat to promote their
respective agendas.
Those cots,
they did it.
Those fucks.
The wine industry went after an absence.
Oh my God,
you can't.
In reality,
it stopped moving and your reality,
according to bruise,
whatever his name is,
it was a cheap adulterated versions of the drink.
Oh,
it was cheap adulterated version to the drink sold by unscrupulous
manufacturers.
Not Unlike Bathtub Gin during prohibition that caused the problems.
Okay.
So they just decided to capitalize on.
It's sort of the same way.
A partnership for drug free America.
Like if you,
um,
if you don't know,
I just do a bit about the dog.
The lady with the talking dog as many comedians did,
but there was a stupid,
it's commercial where the girl would come home from school and the dog would be
like,
Hey,
miss me.
Freund Oh,
you wish you wouldn't get high all the time.
It's the stupidest fucking commercial area.
But then you find out it's stupid as that commercial is that it was made by
something called a partnership for a drug free America.
Well,
when you go into that,
that's where it gets hilarious.
A partnership for a drug free America was financed in part,
at least by alcohol,
tobacco,
and pharmaceutical companies.
So I'm like alcohol companies talking shit about pot is like hookers doing
commercials against strippers.
I'm like,
that's literally what it's like.
This is just cutting out the competition.
That's all it was.
So we were watching these stupid fucking commercials going,
who is making these?
Like what is this?
What's the agenda?
Will the agenda was to stifle competition,
which is mind boggling when you really find out that drug companies that make
trillions of dollars selling drugs.
If you combine the alcohol,
the pharmaceutical industry and the tobacco industry worldwide that has
trillions of dollars,
trillions,
the amount of money is staggering and those fucks.
We're financing a partnership for a drug free America
and they let them fucking Latam.
It's hilarious.
It's like a group of murderers banning together to stop the UFC.
It's,
it's so stupid.
It's so fucking stupid.
Absence in the U S isn't real absence in the u s a few exceptions aside,
the quality and authenticity of the absent found in the u s market.
Huh?
The quantity inauthenticity is very good.
He says,
hmm,
what does that mean?
Hmm?
We saying that it's good.
I don't get it.
In contrast,
the EU market remains heavily contaminated with offerings that amount to
flavored vodka and green dye posing his absence.
Did they reverse it?
Yeah,
it seems like they fucked that.
Oh,
paragraph.
these are myths.
So He's,
it's saying that the u s Oh,
right.
Of course.
Right,
right,
right.
That's the myth.
Oh,
okay.
So the u s absence.
That's good.
I forgot that it was all myths.
Absences from the Czech Republic.
Not True.
Oh,
that's a myth too,
Huh?
I need sugar cube.
It shouldn't be classic method of serving absence involve slowly dripping water
over into the spirit,
often over a sugar cube held on by a special perforated spoon.
But in another tradition that magically appeared in the 19 hundreds,
Baroo says 1990.
Oh,
the 1990s.
Uh,
this,
the sugars first soaked with alcohol and lit with a match though impressive.
The fire ritual is really designed to distract from the fact that a cheap,
an artificial product will not Lucia,
what's that word?
Uh,
or turn cloudy with the addition of water.
Like it should,
it's not necessary.
Okay.
Whatever.
But that should be illegal to,
of course it will.
It's kind of like,
I guess it is legal now,
but all of it should be legal.
Men were,
were fucking babies were babies over here.
It's ridiculous.
Yeah,
it's interesting just going through what's going to be next,
you know,
with the marijuana becoming legal more and more places.
Like what's the next thing that,
that we've been pussies about?
Um,
it's probably harder drugs.
It's probably things like coke.
I mean,
I think they're going to make some sort of an argument for sure that Mtma should
be legal.
All the
had a main studies that they're doing.
They're,
they're saying
that they're going to,
you start using ketamine more and more for depression.
Remember Neal Brennan was talking about that,
that he,
he does ketamine treatments for depression.
Wow.
Tranquilizer.
It's cat tranquilizer.
Yeah,
it's cat.
I was horse.
He might be right.
It's one of those,
pretty sure they use it on cats.
I think it's a veterinary tranquilizer.
I have done it.
It's crazy.
It's most,
well apparently be doing enough of it.
You go into other dimensions and Shit like Brennan and saying when he was
talking about,
he was saying he got an IV dose of it and um,
you are essentially like,
you completely dissolve.
You trip your fucking balls off.
You go into some crazy alternative dimension and you're doing it in a doctor's
office.
Anesthesiologist is treating you for depression.
What these insane 45 minute ketamine trips and uh,
you know,
he leaves there.
He's a little foggy.
Comes to the comic stories a little whacked out.
But other than that,
he's like,
my mind is fine.
He goes and I feel really good.
I think it's really working.
So then I started seeing it popping up all over the place.
Excuse me,
sorry.
Where people are,
I'm talking about using it for depression,
that it's being approved for use for depression.
Apparently it's really effective psychedelic trips in particular in general,
but ketamine in particular.
It's apparently like really effective for depression.
What about,
what do you think about Pa Payoti ceremonies and have you,
have you ever done it?
Pod?
No,
never done it.
Supposed to do it next month and you to totally do it.
You know,
it's um,
it's,
it's some form of,
uh,
it's Mescalin essentially,
and it's from the San Pedro cactus.
I don't know how they extract it.
I don't know how that works.
But the,
uh,
it's not a hallucinogen per se,
I believe.
I believe it actually falls into like a stimulant category.
Hmm.
I want to say what is a barbiturate barbecue is like a downer.
Rent.
Yeah.
It's not that it's supposed to make you puke a lot.
It doesn't always.
I thought then you would go in,
cause I mean just watching movies,
you know,
but like natural born killers,
they went in that whole like thing with flying horses with,
if you're in a coyote you're likely to have a dream catcher on your wall.
You might have one of those,
a feather tattoos,
you know,
like goes down your arm like a band,
like some feathers.
It was a popular one.
Yeah.
Dudes.
Just really the native American culture.
Did they write announce why that guy died off of Anna,
Anna Anaconda,
whatever WASC WASC,
which guy I,
there was a second,
a second death recently of a young kid who,
uh,
died and they kept the body for I think four or five weeks before returning to
the United States,
to the parents.
And they were going to test it out to find out why.
But you know,
it could have been he mixed it with something else,
like an antidepressant or he,
you know,
it's probably a really dangerous,
because I think,
I think some medications,
if you're taking something that a,
is an antidepressant,
like you're not supposed
to do IOWASCA certain ssrs.
And I think also if you're taking anything where it gets really dangerous,
if you're taking anything that's an Emo Maoi and Mano a Dean,
how do say it monoline mean monoamine oxidase inhibitor,
um,
which is a very common in some forms of medication.
And it is the reason why you can take Iowasca and an oral form.
So normally when you like I WASC,
uh,
when you're,
when you're taking,
what you're doing is essentially,
it's like a slow release DMT trip,
right?
DMT is in so many different plants and hundreds,
thousands of even that your body produces something to break it down in your
gut.
So like if you were eating lettuce and the lettuce had DMT in it,
you just trip your fucking balls off,
right?
So your body's like,
well,
this is ridiculous.
We can't just keep tripping every time we have a salad.
So your body produces something called Mano,
Amy and Oxidase and that Maoi is uh,
also I'm a part of the IOWASCA missed the mixture.
The,
uh,
the inhibitor is something called harming.
So what it is is it inhibits your body's natural production of this stuff that
breaks down DMT.
So it allows it to get into your bloodstream and you have this,
this wild,
crazy trip.
But apparently that same active ingredient in harming also exists in a bunch of
prescription medications.
So if you're on that prescription medication and you go and you take this other
stuff as well,
you get this overdose effect and it can be super dangerous for you.
Apparently super dangerous to fuck with that stuff too.
Prescription ones and try to make like your own version of Iowasca like,
uh,
by taking DMT with an Maoi.
Like you got to know what the fuck you're doing.
It can be real,
real dangerous.
It can be super skinny.
You're fucking with brain chemistry.
There's one thing if you're doing something that has like thousands of years of
history,
like if you do mushrooms who fucked dies from mushrooms,
you'd have to do the wrong mushrooms.
If you're getting mushrooms from a reputable source,
not like there is one,
but if,
if you know what you're doing and you get mushrooms,
you grow them yourself.
Let's say it's just mushrooms,
like you know what to expect.
Like you're,
you can get really fucked up but you're going to live right.
But when you start fucking with like pharmaceutical drugs and pills and extracts
and who knows,
man,
who knows?
You could,
you could run into some shit and it's,
you know,
again,
it's part of the problem with things being illegal is that we don't know exactly
how many people don't even know that when you eat weed,
your trip and your fucking balls off on this 11 hydroxy metabolite,
that's,
you're not even getting like the THC I,
how many people know that very few people,
few people do.
It's why it's so much stronger when people freak out about how strong pot
cookies are.
It's not even weed.
It's not even the same drug as smoking it.
But the reason why we don't know is because it's illegal.
They should be teaching that in school and they teach you in school,
like how many ounces of alcohol you could have for a hundred pounds of body
weight in order to worry.
You know,
like if you could drive like you going to have six ounces of beer and then you
could drive in me,
you know?
But if you get over that,
like now you start getting into the illegal area,
we,
everybody kind of knows,
right?
Everybody kind of knows like two beers.
Like you're getting close to the line.
Have you had two beers in the span of a half an hour?
You might be close to the illegal driving line.
Right?
But what does it with eating wheat,
what is it?
What does it with smoking weed,
we don't fucking know.
I mean,
everybody has their own tolerance for sure.
But we don't,
there's no like established number that everybody knows like,
oh,
if you eat this,
you know how many milligrams of you had 10 oh you're fine.
There's because of the fact that it's illegal.
There's all this guessing and you gotta.
It takes a long time to figure it out.
You've got to talk to a bunch of different people and get answers.
Don't talk to Joey Diaz throwing off the curve or an idea.
Don't worry about a cop soccer.
Even though the one you're going to walk on ice,
you might as well dance.
I saw him the other day on periscope just eating.
He's like,
all right,
here,
Lee,
take this and he's like,
they're eating just tons of edibles and then be like,
all right Julie,
you've never done acid.
Well,
open up your tongue here and they just dropped acid eight ish.
Yeah.
Joey goes so deep.
He's not even experiencing reality as we know it because reality is just very
different to lead.
It's guys like,
oh,
I guess acid eating that much as normal.
He enjoys it.
He's turning him into a,
Jody is.
Yeah,
but listen man,
I think about if you're Li right,
there's nice kid,
very smart guy.
He's a sweetheart.
Funny on the show and this fucker as stumbled into a partnership with the
funniest man that's ever lived.
So he has this podcast,
the funniest man that's ever lived.
What does the funniest man that's ever lived?
Do he doses of them every day?
Joey Diaz doses that guy with like 500 milligram cheated choose.
He'll take the wrapper off of a fucking 200 milligram Chiba Chew,
put a 500 milligram in there,
wrap it back up and hand it to him.
Eat a dog the mile.
The mile doesn't line about the fucking number.
200 is normal.
The line about the number,
they say 200 get the fuck outta here to Honda with your fucking faggy 200 I had
like a 40 the other day or something like that.
I was fucked up out of book.
I can't believe that.
You know that Lee thinks 200 is a normal number,
you know?
Yeah.
Those guys go d yeah,
well you know what happens?
They start doing it on a regular basis and then you get used to that insane
experience.
You know,
Joe is used to that insane experience.
He's used to just be and just deep in the hole,
like Alice in chains song down and
it's like he's doing it.
He's getting like a narcotic effect,
you know?
I mean you got to think about like Joey's history,
you know,
Joey,
his whole life,
he's done some sort of drugs and now all he does is smoke weed,
you know,
but his whole life,
he's done like horrible drugs,
the terrible,
terrible drugs and a lot of coke.
The coke was I probably the good one.
You know,
he did a lot of crazy shit.
And so for him,
like he,
I think he probably misses that complete total escape from reality that that you
could get when you eat 500 milligrams achieved with shoes.
You're going,
you're going down man,
like world.
The world will become paper thin.
Walls bulled crumble in front of you like they're made out of dust and you'll
just be just looking over the landscape that is the,
the impending doom of your own body and society and the death of your wife and
children and your friends and everyone dying.
You're going to see that.
That's,
you're going to see on those God Damn Pot Chiba chew 500 milligram death stars
hit to death stars the other day too to death stars too.
I've never even heard of anybody eating two of those things.
Do you ever heard of the desktop?
Oh my God.
Is it,
there's some fucking thing that these guys in northern California May,
I think the same guys who make the gummy bears make the,
uh,
the death stars and they're supposed to be so bad.
Joey was run and trying to give one to Alex Jones last time we were in Austin
together.
Where's Alex Jones?
I got to get them one of these desktops.
Joe Rogan.
I'm going to get one of these desktops.
I'm going to fuck him up.
Last time he had like a loaf of bread gummy where he was cutting slices from may
slice you off on things
like you ready to fucking Deli with them.
Hey you got to try this.
No bridges.
I got this new pursued.
All this fucking guy knows on a make a good pursuit.
Slice and paper thin meet,
laying it down.
That stuff's really good.
You gave me a some truffle the other day from that company and then I pause
right there and I actually know the people that from that company on bows.
They live in Burbank,
they make great stuff.
It's really quality.
It's really quality and the stuff that they're making is all organic.
They don't use corn syrup,
they don't like.
It's really used honey when they're making their baked goods.
So fucking where can he get that?
Cause like I
put this on the Internet and we're talking about things that me and me no
appeal.
Legal federally,
federally.
What a creepy situation that is.
The federal government still like that's why these,
these guys that are running for president on the Republican side,
some of them are so fucking scary because if they really do say do what they say
they're going to do and get into office and then all of sudden go after these
pot shops,
start rating them like you're looking at like some civil war shit.
They still doing it.
It's,
it's still happening.
I don't know what hair braiding any shingle,
but they're talking about it.
This Chris Christie guy especially,
no one thinks he can actually become president,
but if he did become president,
he,
one of things that he said he would do
is immediately go into Colorado and Washington state and shut down all the pot
sales.
See that black guy now he's the fee.
That's Ben Carson.
That's the religious.
He's fascinating,
man.
That guy's fascinating.
I've been paying attention to him a lot lately.
He's really interesting.
Ben Carson is one of the best pediatric brain surgeons in the world like he has.
He is saved conjoined twins when conjoined twins were linked together at the
head.
Like this is the,
apparently these kids,
they were sharing a one artery that's a very important already that I think more
than 20 different doctors or a bunch of different doctors at work,
20 hours,
um,
to,
uh,
to try to help these kids.
And they survived.
They separated their fucking brains.
They were conjoined twins,
meaning their,
their bodies are connected together at the head and he saved them.
Like he's a brilliant,
brilliant man when it comes to that.
But then when it comes to like evolution,
Big Bang theory,
yeah,
he believes the Big Bang Theory is a myth.
He doesn't believe in evolution.
Why is it always like that?
It's like,
you know,
you got your so smart in one area,
but then you,
you completely miss judge everything and the other area,
like,
it's like you're,
it's like it doesn't make sense at all.
Doesn't make sense.
It's um,
because you know,
we all know people that are really good at one thing and they suck at other
stuff.
And the more attention you put to this one thing,
oftentimes he neglect areas of your life.
Like how many like tortured geniuses.
That's a really common term that people love to use.
You know,
always just tortured genius,
like someone who's a genius in like their musical life.
But in their personal life it's just constant chaos.
They're an asshole and screaming people and throw things around.
Like what?
What is that?
But ultimately you look at it,
if you separate yourself from society's idea of how you should behave or
shouldn't behave,
and society's idea of like what's aesthetically pleasing about some kinds of
music and how difficult it is to do is just look at it like,
uh,
just outside of culture,
right?
Well you just,
you look at it like a mathematical problem.
You Go,
Whoa,
this is real simple.
This guy has resources,
right?
And he's dumped all the resources into this one thing like running.
He's like,
he's,
he's the best runner of all time,
but his personal life is chaos.
It was family.
Fucking hates him.
His friends,
he's a backstabber like,
like the Lance Armstrong situation.
You know guys like the baddest fucking biker of all time.
Meanwhile he's still in people.
The people that are saying that he did drugs,
he's like,
I'll fucking sue you.
I'm suing this person.
I'm suing that.
It's got all this chaos going on like that.
It was this overwhelming desire for victory sort of takes over pretty much every
aspect of the rest of your life.
Like they say Michael Jordan,
you can't even play pool with that guy.
If you beat him at pool,
he will fucking hate you.
He hates you because what does his thing,
well his thing is just winning is overwhelming.
Thing is winning and I don't know what he's like in real life but I haven't
heard good things are very lucky.
It doesn't tip of her and like weird shit like that.
You know?
Like cause it's not necessarily the nicest guy.
What could that be?
Well it could be like he's,
it didn't focus on that.
He focused everything on this one thing.
Everything on this one thing.
This is what's important I think.
I think you get a lot of that with people.
I think this Ben Carson Guy,
it's just,
he probably focused so much on that that he didn't,
didn't apply that objective reasoning and that intellect to examining the
various aspects of the mythology that is accepted as his reality.
I mean,
because Christianity at the end of the day with no proof,
everything is mythology,
everything with no proof with proof.
Then you examine the proof.
It's super simple and anybody that argues against that is just,
you're just biased.
You,
you have your own ideas.
If you have some proof that there was a god that does,
God had one son and he made the sun come down and get the fuck beat out of him
and nailed to a board so that we could all have no sin.
Do you have,
can you show me some studies?
Can you give it,
do you have a box of evidence that you can pull out and we can examine all the
different pieces that points to the undeniable conclusion that that's true.
Because if you don't,
then it's a myth.
Then you're,
you're believing mythology.
It doesn't mean it's not real.
But if you,
if you put all your fucking eggs in that basket and you don't have any proof at
all,
well you're entering into this weird world where you don't pay attention to
shit.
You're entering into this weird world where you,
you ignore certain aspects of things because you've decided what is and what
isn't.
That's not thinking.
That's like it's convenient cookie holder placement of ideas.
It's not thinking because if you're thinking you can't accept it,
if you're thinking you'd go,
wait,
what?
He came back from the dead.
Has anyone ever done that?
Three days came back from the dead.
I don't think you can do that.
And people,
I mean that's what people would do normally,
but you know,
like I went to,
my kid had a function today and I went to this function and they're all,
uh,
we're singing God bless America and there's like some something about heaven in
their,
and their school prayer.
I'm like,
well,
okay,
are we teaching people?
We're teaching kids things,
right?
What's heaven?
Where's this?
Is this a real thing?
Or we just pretending to heaven's real so the kids feel good and they can get
through a 12th grade.
What are we doing here?
What are we doing?
You know,
W W we have to make shit up about stuff that we don't know and instead of just
accepting what we do know,
instead of just celebrating and accepting what we know about life,
we have to pretend that there's a heaven and you're going to go to heaven when
you die.
What the fuck are you talking about?
Like you're,
you're teaching my kid nonsense.
Why don't you teach him some rumper?
Bumbles stills can shit once you make some shit up about you're making shit up
about heaven.
I'm not saying heaven doesn't exist,
but you're just making it up.
You're teaching a school in a class,
you're making them and then in heaven,
God in Heaven,
where is heaven?
Who's God?
What are you talking about?
You making up some shit.
You're making up some shit in a school like,
and you don't have to.
Okay,
look,
if the kid comes to you like,
um,
where is heaven on a map?
Can you,
uh,
can you take me to is,
do we have a Google earth?
Could we check on heaven?
Can I see,
can I see the harp?
Oh Man.
You know,
heaven is his heavenly father.
That was the other thing.
Heavenly father,
our heavenly father.
Really,
this is what we're teaching in school.
Heavenly fathers,
how can we start a check?
You know,
moms are usually better at raising you.
Been Dad's dad's working all the time.
It is weird that that when you have a kid that you do nothing but lie to them.
Their,
their first 10 years of their life,
like about Santa Claus,
bunny rabbits,
Jesus monsters.
Well,
the Jesus thing keeps going.
That's the weirdest part of it.
And again,
it's just not saying that Jesus wasn't real.
Just saying like if you looked,
if that story existed in any other form other than religion,
you'd be like,
why?
If you look at that for that story outside of religion,
if it wasn't something that you know you,
you made the sign of the cross every morning and went to school and prayed.
If you just read the story about a guy who was magic and could turn water into
wine,
who could heal people?
What did he do at fish?
Did he fucking give people fish or some shit?
Make some fish.
The whole thing is so stupid.
You'd be like,
wait a minute.
Who told you this?
Well,
it's a long story.
So he,
it was actually spoken about for about a thousand years for anybody bothered to
write it down.
You'd be like,
wait,
what?
Shut the fuck up.
They told it for a thousand years.
The Old Testament,
they told the Old Testament for a thousand years they use,
it was,
it was spoken for a thousand years.
That's so long.
That's like,
just stop and think how fucking stupid that is.
That literally,
that would be like going back to like the Julius Caesar Days and Julius Caesar
like a thousand years ago was that the Romans were around a thousand years ago.
Right?
No.
Before that it'd be like Genghis Khan.
It'd be like Genghis Khan's life and no one bothers to write it down until now.
I mean,
that's so stupid.
The idea behind that is so stupid that you could tell a story for a thousand
years and get it right when you write it down.
It is,
it is interesting.
Like,
you know,
Pope,
uh,
you know,
he believes in the Big Bang theory and I evolutions real.
So it seems like they kind of have to slowly start accepting everything,
but when it comes down to it,
they still believe it.
You know what magic man,
you know Jesus flying it around with.
I tell you what,
man,
it always weirds me out when they have that guy on TV.
It weirds me the fuck out.
It weirds me out.
I was watching Cole Bear.
It was so strange,
man.
It was cold bear and Gaf again,
who I love,
Jim Gaffigan and Maria Shriver and some other weird dude.
And uh,
they were sitting around talking about what it means to be a catholic.
I was like,
why not?
Like,
what are you talking about?
And they were talking about forgiveness and Catholicism is all about
forgiveness.
And Maria Shriver is like being all proud to be a Catholic and they're showing
the mass and like I'm like,
hit the brakes.
Aren't you grown adults like you guys are,
you're in the nonsense so you're into nonsense.
Is that what this is?
Cause this is what you're showing nonsense.
You get this guy dressed like he's in a fucking Harry Potter movie and He's
standing in front of all these people with a chalice.
He's wearing a cult outfit.
He literally is wearing a cult outfit from a thousand years ago and you're all
sitting there listening to this nonsense,
total nonsense he sent even speaking in English and you're there,
you're like,
yes,
we're here.
We're here to whisk.
Witnessed the Holy Father.
Like what the fuck are you talking?
You're there to witness a guy who works for an organization that owns a building
that houses the largest gay bathhouse in Europe.
Yeah,
that's the Vatican owns.
I mean did the whole thing is so fucking ridiculous and that this guy is meeting
with all these people all across America and they're all so happy to meet the
pope.
This is so amazing.
And he listens to people's stories and he decides whether or not people should
be able to get married if they're gay.
The whole,
it's hilarious.
He supported that Kim Davis Lady,
the lady went to the Vatican.
They,
they,
they had uh,
a meeting with her.
She got an audience at the Vatican.
Oh,
he told her that,
uh,
he was saying that people shouldn't have to violate their beliefs.
So there's essentially he was supporting her who was supporting her decision not
to marry gay people.
Yeah.
When I first heard it,
I wonder if he just pulled her aside and like,
look man,
it's 2015 just let it go,
going to make,
so I think probably like,
listen,
bitch,
keep that shit up.
I don't want to marry any dude.
That's probably what it,
like.
I'll keep my money,
look at all this money.
I want to see my gold.
Take her to a fucking like smog chamber from the Hobbit.
Just gold everywhere.
It's tacked up the ceiling.
Have you seen the footage of him smell?
Have you seen that footage of him sucking on toes?
The,
you know,
that's a thing he does.
That's the thing that he does.
He goes around in,
sucks on guides,
toes come on.
So I swear to God,
I dare you.
Oh,
come on.
When you're talking about they should on the news.
It's like pope visited in blessed all these people and it's just him like
kissing toes and like,
well I think he shows us humility by kissing your feet.
Yeah.
It was very gross dudes.
Cause and dude's feet.
Yeah.
He was getting the foot part.
Totally depends what part of the foot.
Like
if you kiss like my Shin,
my instep,
instep,
I consider a weapon.
It's like kissing and knuckle.
But if you suck on my little pinky toe,
right.
I have a problem with that.
Yeah.
I just googled,
pope kissed his feet and the first thing is humbling moment.
Pope Francis Washes brome prisoners.
So it's just him washing a bunch of guys.
Mm.
He washes them.
Why can't they wash themselves?
What,
what is going on here?
Washing them for the Lord first I will start with the balls.
Then I washed the taint.
Pope Francis kisses and wash his feet of young offenders at room prison after.
God dammit.
I remember.
It's one of the things that Jesus did as he was growing up.
How convenient they wrote it.
Not Look.
Hold on.
It's right here.
It says right here.
Jesus said,
thou must suck if the toes,
man,
he's getting in there.
It's like,
yes.
He's deep in there.
While it's an addendum.
Oh my hair.
He goes,
I was kissing the girl's feet.
Oh,
he's washing the girl's feet.
Those are hot feet though.
She's got a cute little feet that's different.
So foot fetish they love.
Oh,
they must be whacking off crazy to this hope.
Help kids.
Pope pope play.
Um,
I got introduced to this a girl by,
um,
uh,
Chris Ryan,
the author of,
um,
sex at dawn.
And uh,
he,
uh,
he's friends with this girl who she's like a dominatrix and humiliate tricks.
She humiliates dudes and a,
she sells her socks and she's got all these pictures on her Twitter of her like
dirty socks or their foot like up to you like one sock off,
one sock on.
She was like 300 bucks by my socks.
You pigs.
Yeah,
I know a couple of his curls.
Duncan do a marrow like that for a long time.
Munchies,
Stan Sher,
stinky mouth or whatever her name was.
She just,
she came to my house to a party at one time for his birthday.
The fuck was her name and she mass.
Yeah,
there was like some crazy name and she had her underwear and it was just like,
and it's just like the old days
Brown.
Yeah.
Well she would have deals where she would have to wear socks like many days in a
row.
So they would really stink and then she would sell them.
Duncan's girl did.
She would like to have deals.
Like I got to wear them for three days.
Like she'd be like,
what?
Come with,
I'm going to walk my dog.
I gotta get these socks.
Nice and stinky
walking around in socks.
You know what's here?
Here's something weird socks like cotton socks stink.
So fucking bad.
The worst though is like plastic.
You ever have like some sort of nylon material in the socks?
I've had athletic socks that were so bad.
Like I'd wear them for a couple hours and they would just fucking Rick where I'd
have to throw my sneakers and the washing machine like what's that smell?
But with doesn't smell is wool.
When I go hunting we can
wear the same socks.
I wear the same socks for like days in a row,
days in a row.
They don't stink.
It's weird cause it's wool.
Somehow or another we'll wool.
Here's another thing about wool,
Merino wool specialty I guess maybe all wall,
but when it gets wet you stay warm.
Whereas like if cotton gets wet,
you're fucked.
Like so when you hunt,
a lot of times it's cold as shit out,
but you're dressed heavily and your walking like up hills and you heat up and
you start sweating.
Well if you weren't cotton,
it's really fucking dangerous cause that's how people get hypothermia.
They start walking,
they walk up hills and then they sit down and they fucking freeze to death
because your,
your whole body's like soaking wet from walking and then you sit and you're
like,
oh Jesus.
Like you get tired and you can't go on anymore.
Well you got wet clothes on,
man.
You,
you got to make a fire to dry your clothes off.
You gotta take your clothes off and dry them by the fire or you're not gonna
make it.
But if you have wool on,
it's crazy.
You could be wet and you're still warm.
It's real weird.
It's a,
it's a non synthetic.
a,
it's a biological hair and because it's wool was lamb's wool because it's
coming,
you know,
as lamb's hair,
it,
uh,
it preserves heat better and it,
it,
it's like the reaction that it has to moisture's completely different and like
retains heat.
It's real weird.
You think it would make it stink here?
Yeah.
You would think so.
We think it would smell got dead sheep or something.
Right.
She funk,
but it doesn't,
man,
it's like this.
The,
like one of the best ways to prevent your body from really stinking when you go
on these trips.
Cause like when we're in Montana and the first time when,
when I got that deer right there,
we were outside for five days,
six days without a shower.
And I'm sure I didn't smoke great for sure.
You know,
especially my,
but
I was just shitting in a hole in the ground and uh,
taking toilet paper and they would like the toilet paper on fire to burn it off.
That's,
that's what you would do.
Something with my asshole must have just been a disaster.
Lucky.
I don't have to look at it though.
But um,
after five days of,
uh,
you know,
being,
um,
in the,
in the woods like that,
like I had the same clothes on for five days.
And what was,
it wasn't that hard.
We weren't like,
I didn't have to pry them off my skin,
you know,
that gets like your socks sometimes.
The other day we have to like pry them away from the bottom of your skin.
It's like they stick in the pores and then they become hard like,
like,
like crunchy.
Where's the crunchy come from?
That was in your foot.
It's toxic.
This is man.
It's toxins,
this foot toxins.
Someone was trying to tell me that they'd like to go to someplace.
It might have been Joey.
They'd go to some place.
They put your foot and his bath.
Yeah.
It's the toxins come out and it's black.
It's black and the bottom and go,
whoa,
Whoa,
whoa.
What fucking toxins are your,
what are you eating charcoal like good
to fucking talk to you about.
I've always wanted to see if that's real.
I don't know.
He always talks about that.
It's not real.
I think it's a trick.
Someone told me about the trick to someone explained to me what the trick is.
It's like some sort of a chemical that they put in the water and there's a
chemical reaction to your skin and it makes us like black color and you,
you start thinking,
oh my God,
the toxins are coming out.
Cara Santa Maria is pretty funny about that shit man.
You know,
cause she's so smart.
She's a scientist.
She was uh,
she goes,
it's one of the surefire ways to tell someone that's full of shit.
And they start talking about cleansing.
They started talking about toxins and cleansing and she's like,
wait,
wait.
What?
What is going on here with your toxins?
Yeah,
the did the brown wire is probably your dirty feet.
Just wash.
You probably washed your feet for you.
You know,
I think if there's an actual black like a little or something.
Yeah,
there's like something that they put in the water and when your feet react to
it,
it just makes us black liquid with,
it's not toxins.
You imagine if that's all it took.
You Soak your feet in,
the blackness comes out of you or you see like little demons fucking swirling
around the water.
The spirit still leaving your feet.
They fucking,
they hide out in your feet.
That's why you feed her at the end of the day,
it's coasts.
I did,
I had a weird thing happened to me yesterday.
I don't know if I told you about my,
my vision.
I just started tripping out of nowhere.
Like my,
my,
yeah,
I did hear about that.
My eyes weren't,
uh,
like the light wasn't hitting my eyes right.
Like my eyes weren't adjusting to light.
Right.
So if I looked at my arm and I wave my arm,
it looked like there was like a blue line around it at points,
like very neon trippy,
like laser kind of like if you see like,
uh,
a film with a low exposure rate,
you know,
where you see like the weird trippy stuff.
And if I blinked my eyes,
everything got really bright for a second and then it went dark,
like darker.
So it's like I was seeing through a filter and somebody said they think it's an
ocular Migraine,
which is a migraine that you don't have a headache but your eyes from stressing
it,
looking at computers or lack of sleep,
uh,
that,
that happens.
But I've had it happen twice in a month.
Right.
That makes sense.
If it happens once,
it means you know,
your,
your eyes are weak by whatever you're doing,
I think,
I think looking at monitors,
it's fucking terrible.
You know,
I did a podcast last week where I didn't bring the laptop and we do the fight
companion podcast.
My eyes felt better by the end of the day.
It was like at the end of that,
like I think staring at a screen like that,
I mean I,
my screen is too bright,
but I think staring at a screen like that all the time,
I just think it's real bad for you.
I'm just totally unnatural to be staring in a light source like that six,
you know,
a foot,
two feet from your face,
especially a phone where you usually squinting.
It's not like a fixed screen.
Phones are terrible.
It's great.
What they do is amazing.
I mean the,
I would never give them back.
I would never say man,
brother grew book to fucking smoke signals.
You know,
I love phones,
but the
what they're doing,
he is not good.
It's just not good.
It's just not good to be staring at my eyes or it's significantly worse than
they were three or four years ago.
Yeah,
it goes fast.
Huh?
That's interesting.
Yeah,
it's not good.
I bought a book,
um,
that's direct.
Um,
Steve Maxwell recommended,
but I haven't gotten to it.
I think there's,
the irony is not lost on me that it,
when I'm wearing reading glasses,
reading a book about how to not read with glasses
or wearing reading glasses.
And when I'm reading a book about how to not use reading glasses while I'm
reading with glasses,
it's a book about not reading.
Yeah.
It's like throw away your glasses and see,
I think it's the name of the book.
I'm like,
it's hilarious.
I'm reading this book while I'm wearing glasses.
That's him.
That book makes zero sense.
It,
I,
there's,
it's like,
I think it's called the Bates method for,
um,
strengthening your eyes.
The idea is that your eyes are like any other part of your body and you,
if you use them properly,
you can strengthen them.
But if you don't use them properly,
you can weaken them.
You know,
like if you breathe in coal fumes all day,
you're gonna fuck up your lungs.
So the idea is if you're staring at a computer screen all day,
you're fucking up your eyes and there may be ways to sort of at least partially
mitigate the damage that you're doing to your eyes.
Play some quake.
Yeah.
That's supposed to be good for your eyes,
right?
God dammit.
Can't get me in there man.
I know.
What's wrong with me?
I,
that's one that's one that I can't go back to.
It's just too much.
I liked it too much.
I just,
I'm a,
I'm doing too well without it.
That's really what your eyes,
your eyes more than that book.
Maybe.
I don't think it,
well,
I just think,
uh,
it will be one hour and then it'll be two hours and then it'll be four hours a
day.
And the next thing you know,
I'm not writing any new jokes.
I'm not going to the Improv or the comedy store.
I'm not sitting in front of the computer or a pen and paper and getting shit
done.
No [inaudible] Jones and Jones and Niggle frag people to go fucking chain gun,
someone rail,
gun them.
And it's fun.
If you twitch for three hours and then you got some comedy out of it.
Yeah,
you can make it a podcast.
What comedy would I get out of it?
Bullshit with people.
You might get a judge.
I don't know about all that.
Have you ever bought I bought kiss somebody like touched eyeballs.
It's cool how we'll do it again.
It's no it,
it's cool.
No,
I have it was weird.
You're like touch to it to a girl.
I love it.
It's so,
it's weird touching something that somebody sees through.
There was a story about a dude who died.
Um,
I don't know if it's true,
so I should probably look it up.
Um,
he got staph infection on his eyeball because during the wrestling match,
it's contact lens came out,
it fell on a mat,
took it,
put it back in his eye and a,
I got a staph infection as I want up dying.
That could be one of those fucking leprechauns.
It makes sense.
I mean,
I,
herpes is a real thing and that's actually pretty common.
And you get outbreaks on your eyes.
Is I herpes a real thing?
Yeah.
Really.
I herpes,
I heard eyeballs.
You can get herpes and your eyeballs.
Yeah,
I heard police,
ocular herpes leads.
Ocular herpes.
So like when you go to close your eyelids,
like as you blinking,
it's going over that giant Zit pops your eyeballs.
Oh my God.
How old are you?
How bold do you have to be to pop and eyeballs that can imagine if you popped it
and you felt that ooze.
Oh
yeah.
You probably can't pop and eye balls it cause it would.
If it gets infected.
Fuck,
that's not good.
It don't Google image search.
I herpes either just stop and think about some of the fucked up diseases that
people can get.
You don't even know about them until they happen.
And then you go,
wait,
what do I have?
I bought herpes surfers at one time.
I've ever seen that.
No,
that's real brown.
Yeah.
Oh God.
Look up.
What is surfers?
Overexposure to Sun.
It's called pterygium.
I can't say that right,
but oh wow.
Cocular mucus extension.
I don't know what happens.
It just starts taking over your,
I think it's the where like I cancer.
Oh my God.
And a,
what do they do about it?
I think you're fucking,
did you guys lose your eye?
Oh my God.
Really?
I mean,
I don't think I can go look how much that one guy the it gets.
It's a woman.
The black one.
Oh God.
This is too horrible.
Oh my God.
Look at that.
Look how it's overcoming her vision.
Look at what's going on with this guy.
Same thing.
Surfer.
Now he's got it.
He's a victim of surf rage.
Oh,
that guy got his ass lit up.
Does he have it?
Kelly Slater has it.
Do you see it on Kelly Slater?
He's just coming up.
Wow.
This is crazy.
I know.
They get an ear thing to surfers get surfer ear where the inside of their ear.
Um,
they develop like these nodes,
like these big bony protrusions.
Scary Shit,
man.
Yeah.
I had her friend can't be that good.
I had a sunburn in my eye once because I was sitting at a table after a rain
storm and the sun had reflected off the table into my eyes for two hours while
it's just sitting there drinking or whatever.
And the next like couple hours later,
I couldn't see out of my eyes for like two days.
Whoa.
It was just burned.
My eyes were burning.
You had no idea.
No idea.
It was going on so bright.
I'm not looking at the sun.
It'll be
again booze.
Yeah,
that was,
you'd be like,
I need some sunglasses,
man.
Yeah,
this is bullshit,
man.
It sucked because I had to go out in public and like,
I remember I went to red lobster and I couldn't see.
My Dad had to like walk me through red lobster.
Oh my God.
Did you hear that?
Um,
uh,
ed Snowden joined Twitter.
Yeah.
You got like a million followers and an hour.
He's at 1.1 9 billion.
Interesting.
And he did Neil degrasse Tyson's podcast.
Neil degrasse Tyson is such a bad motherfucker.
He wrote this on Twitter.
You would ed stone after discussing everything from chemistry to Constitution on
Star Trek.
Star Talk.
You're a patriot.
To me.
Safe stay safe.
Poor fucking guy who is following.
He's only following one.
One account.
Yeah,
the NSA.
Hilarious.
That is,
that is fucking hilarious.
That's how I comedy.
Oh,
poor bastard.
That's one of those things,
man,
like where's that going to be 2030 years from now?
Cause like living in Russia,
we're just speculating.
But I would imagine that's a,
this is,
well,
you know what though,
man,
if anybody would not,
I was gonna say it's probably terrifying you were living under this
dictatorship,
but if anybody would feel that it's not like that,
it's him because he knows what America is like.
I mean they're trying to put that fucking guy in jail and why they tried to put
them in jail for exposing crime.
That's why they're trying to put them in jail.
They're trying to put him in jail for the very thing that Obama used to have on
it's hope and change campaign website and his hope and change campaign website.
Before Obama became elected,
he had this whole thing about whistle blowers that they would support
whistleblowers people that we're exposing crime and that they wouldn't punish
these people.
They would help them.
But meanwhile,
he's been the worst for whistle blowers.
It's,
it was bullshit.
You know,
he didn't really have the power that he claimed to have or would have when he
got in and then when he did get in,
he didn't do any of the things he said he would do when it comes to whistle
blowers,
nor did he support them publicly.
He kept his fucking mouth shut or he spoke disparagingly about stolen.
Meanwhile,
if you ask the American people,
if he gave like a pole,
like if everybody on Twitter,
how to vote,
how many people are happy with what Ed Snowden did and how many people think
that what he did was dangerous in each be in jail.
I guarantee you most people,
especially people that know what the case was actually about,
they would,
they would support him.
He went way out of his way to make sure that no one got in trouble or that no
one was doxed,
that their information wasn't released and that critical operations weren't
compromised.
He went way out of his way and he brought that shit to a bunch of different
sources before he brought it to Glenn Greenwald.
There was a bunch of different people he brought it to that they didn't want to
have anything to do with it.
The whole thing is just so strange.
It's terrifying.
You think Obama might help him out before he gets out of,
uh,
help him out.
Like maybe like not excommunicate him cause he's not in prison right now,
but he should totally do that back.
You should do that right now.
He should do that right now.
He should have a speech and he should tell the American public that what the NSA
did cross the line and that the average American person is not a criminal and we
shouldn't be treated as a criminal until proven differently.
It's not,
that's not how democracy works and that kind of pressure.
Here's the living your life under that kind of pressure is awful.
Nobody wants to live like that.
Worrying that people looking over your shoulder because it affects your freedom.
It affects the way you think and behave.
You didn't,
you feel like you're being observed and watched and that that has a big impact
on how you behave and think if you're constantly,
like if you ever walk,
worked in a place where your boss,
I'm like thought you were a untrustworthy or thought you were sneaky and
they're,
you know,
or you know,
didn't like you in any way and they're always like checking in on your work and
they're always following you around rally it makes working in that office a
fucking nightmare.
You're spending eight hours a day with some fucking guy who is constantly
looking at you sideways,
who imagine turn it to 24 hours a day and that's what the CIA or the NSA is
doing.
I mean,
they're,
they're your boss there.
Dick checking in on you.
Let me look at your Google search.
What do you give a shit about torture?
Why?
Why are you in,
I mean,
what if you want to find out how they torture people like you're allowed to as
an adult.
Okay.
As a fucking grown adult and you say torture tactics of Isis.
Like I want to know what they do.
Let's see what they do.
Okay,
let's see what they do in China.
Let's see what they do.
Why,
why you looking at it?
Woo.
The fuck are you?
I'm looking at it because it's a possible search result.
I want to ask a question.
I want to know why is that bad?
What's not bad?
But if you start googling weird shit about Islam or isis or you know,
how do you convert?
What if I want to know how you convert?
How's that work?
What do I have?
What if I wander around?
What's the protocol?
How do I join one?
If I want to know am I going to get visited cause I want to have,
if I'm not joining Isis Guy dammit.
But if I want to have some information,
like maybe I'm wanting to be able to,
you know,
answer that question.
If someone says,
how do they join isis?
I researched that actually they,
this is what they do.
Well if you start looking at all that shit,
they will put you on a fucking list and the wolves,
they're putting you on that list for your own good.
Are they really?
How about you just catch people?
They do crime.
How about you just prevent crime from happening and not by making everyone a
criminal.
When you start looking at everybody's fucking email,
you start recording everybody's phone calls.
You start taking everybody's text messages and putting them in a database.
Fuck you.
You know,
and we all agree with that.
Meanwhile,
this poor guy,
he's in Russia,
cut pussy thing.
He's getting over there.
It's funny how Facebook does that legally,
right?
Hot ones,
You know,
hot rush.
How many accounts do you have?
A lot.
Uh,
connected to Facebook.
You know how like,
it's like log in with Facebook,
you know,
if you forget how many times you do that.
And then there's a,
there's a setting somewhere in Facebook where you can see everything you've
done.
And like the other day I looked at it,
it was like,
Oh,
you listen to this song at three o'clock.
Then you ordered food from this place.
Then you took an Uber to this.
And then I was just like,
Holy Shit.
So you have so much information.
Yeah.
So can anybody else look at it?
No.
But,
but Facebook has all that and I've,
and I've been doing it for years.
You just forget when you log in with Facebook,
how much you actually use that use Facebook or you're telling Facebook what
you're doing,
but you forget that you're logged in to eat 24 with Facebook.
You're logged into Facebook.
I don't do that.
I don't use Facebook to log in to anything.
Yeah I do.
Because it's easy.
It's like in town we don't have to sign up to me like that's not good.
Especially a database like Facebook where they sell your shit because they sell
your shit.
Like they're there.
They're all coming up with new and better ways to profit off of the list that
they can generate.
But when you're buying habits arm like you know how,
when is it that always weirds me out like you Google something because the other
day I was googling a specific type of binocular swore off ski.
They're like very famous binoculars.
So I'm googling,
I'm looking at the different types of binoculars.
Then I go to some website and there's a fucking Swarovski add in the Google ad
things.
Cause they know I've been looking like,
oh,
what about this?
Why don't you buy that and now you think about it man.
And I was like,
wow,
that's Kinda fucked up.
It's kind of weird that they tailor the ads to you because I never saw hunting
binocular ads and some fucking buzzfeed website.
Like all of a sudden I see it like why am I seeing that there?
Because it's tailored to my search results and,
and you know,
just saying all of Guardian right now,
we'll make all of garden play on Youtube.
You know,
because they go through the audio of youtube videos and if there's certain
advertising olive garden right now and it will make,
there will be an all garden ad at the beginning of the podcast.
A lot of times.
Yeah.
If it's,
if it's a current site paid sponsor from Youtube,
does that mean that they do a transcript of the show?
They all,
everything is transcript now.
Any video you put out nowadays,
there's a transcript of imagine trying to transcribe one of our Sros.
Oh,
it's done.
Yeah.
But I mean,
imagine if you tried to look,
if you took parts of it.
That's like one of the problems that I have with uh,
people taking a little snippets of the podcast and then having making whole
articles about a conversation that was said because you're,
you're taking something that's completely out of context and all the humor and
irony and sarcasm Mollett shits completely missing.
You just get a sentence,
you know,
like me telling Milo yesterday,
your k is fuck dude,
like buzz.
What was it?
Buzzfeed news or was it raw story?
Story.
They make it,
you look at it and go,
what is he saying here?
Like why is he saying that to him?
Like it looks so much different when you see something like transcribed.
Like transcription is not necessarily a really good,
um,
it,
it's,
it's not the full capturing of a conversation.
It's just not,
and try to pretend it is like when someone,
if someone like put something in quotes and says that,
you know,
Hillary Clinton said this,
okay,
can I see how she said it?
Can I see who she was talking to?
Can you show me a video of what they were talking about before then?
Because then I'll only understand what she's really saying and that's how emojis
were born.
That's the purpose of right at the hand of the side.
Like,
oh,
she's been cunty cause that what the hand to the side
walk like an Egyptian.
I didn't know that.
I don't use emojis.
You don't?
Oh,
I'm so deep in emojis and the new ones are about to come out.
Like we've got in the ways Taco Tacos on the way and I already have piles of
shit and the guns of gun emojis or sometimes people send me a text and I'm like,
I don't know what you're saying,
but I think you're going to shoot the shit.
Shoot Shit.
I overuse eggplant.
Eggplant.
Why do you use that one for Coq au,
your deck eggplant.
That's the international dick.
If your Dick looks like that with that,
that it's probably dying.
You probably have a horrible infection.
You need to go get your Dick drained at gs.
Eggplant Sushi,
squirt the three drops of water.
That's uh,
that's one way to say a sentence.
Will a woman,
you know,
it's a funny thing about the way we do language that we think of that as like
the only way to do language.
But if you look at like hieroglyphs that's kind of what they did.
They just talk and Emojis,
I mean the Egyptians,
they drew all their shit like there were,
oh here we are pushing a rock.
Here we are with the boat.
You know,
this guy has a sword.
Do they know if the hieroglyphs written by smart people or not?
Has that ever come up?
Well,
they were the smartest people around.
Otherwise it'd be people that had hieroglyphs are making fun of hieroglyphs no
fire.
He smart.
Oh what does that mean?
And you know,
there was smart like that could have the hieroglyphs that are found could have
been written by the dumb kids or whatever.
They were just frightened in emojis to each other.
That's the only ones that got found or you know what I mean?
Well,
it used to be a thing called the library of Alexandria,
but it was burned,
burned to the ground more than once,
I think.
I think the Muslims burned it down and I think about,
I think someone else burnt it down to,
I want to say,
I forget who it is,
but they,
uh,
they lost all their records.
They lost all their,
he said people used to go to Egypt from all over the world to learn.
They used to have psychedelic studies there.
They used trip balls.
They used to fucking learn about mathematics and construction techniques and we
don't know what the fuck they taught them.
We don't know what the fuck they knew.
We don't know anything.
We just see amazing,
amazing shit that they left behind and go,
fuck how the hell they do this.
We don't know.
We just guess just a bunch of guesswork
once the scientists that every now and then someone will put together a paper.
We've solved the riddle of how they made the pyramids.
It's quite simple actually.
No,
it's not.
Do you know it's not carved it out of a mountain.
It's not even a little simple.
It's crazy.
Those things are giant and they're perfect.
The Great Pyramid is 2 million,
600,000 stones.
They're cut so perfectly that you can't even like wedge a sheet of paper.
You can get a razor blade in between the stones in most cases.
The ones that you see on the outside that are rough and horrible.
The reason why they're rough is because of the pyramid used to be covered in
smooth limestone.
It used to be this beautiful,
smooth,
flat surface,
but when they were building Cairo,
those fucking apes,
like a thousand years later,
2000 years later,
whatever it was,
they stole all the limestone from the pyramids.
They chipped it,
chipped it away,
pulled it off,
and built their streets with it.
Fucking dummies.
It's so you imagine how fucking stupid they had to be to chip away at the
outside of the pyramid.
Take the limestone off fucking morons.
You think maybe the pyramids or it's just a mountain and they just carved the
pyramid out of the mountain.
I think you need to read.
I need to read books.
It makes sense.
That was a one of the explanations for what the Sphinx was.
The Sphinx was what they call a yard.
Dang,
what a yard.
Dang is.
When you say like you've ever seen,
like they always have these like mountains where the side of the mountain looks
like an Indian's head.
The idea is you take something like that and then you start actually carving
away at it until it really looks like a sphinx.
And the idea was that there was this rock that looked similar to that.
It's like some standout rock and then they did all this stuff to it.
The problem with that is,
uh,
there's,
there's just a lot of evidence for how they built that thing.
They know how the carved it out,
the temple that the Sphinx is in that area that shows all the water erosion.
Like they know where the blocks are.
Like they take them from here,
they move them to their blocks are missing.
So they're,
they're pretty sure that it's fucked.
That's another weird one because there's finks like they're reconstructing it
and when they're reconstructing it,
they're just building on the outside of it.
Like they're doing such a shitty job.
Like if you ever seen like the reconstruction photos,
this his help my case making like concrete.
They are,
they're,
they're making like they're doing their own art and they're covering over the
old shit.
Like I guess they have to,
to preserve it because I guess it's crumbling and falling apart.
So a lot of it is just to try to preserve it,
but like a JBC if he could pull up some pictures of the restoration of the
Sphinx because it's,
uh,
it's real controversial because when you look at it like you're not really
looking at the Sphinx anymore.
You're looking at a modern interpretation of covering the outside of the feet
and parts of the base.
It's not really the sphinx anymore.
Like watch the WWE,
they show the,
the feet like see that the upper right hand,
the middle,
the middle.
Sorry.
We the middle.
You can see
why.
Yeah,
yeah.
Go to go to view image and spread that out.
It looks like they just got,
well,
we'll just patch it up.
Yeah.
$5.
Who Look what they're doing.
They just have modern bricks and they're smoothing it all out.
So I mean,
yeah,
I guess it looks good.
Like,
in terms of,
you know,
it's,
it's smooth stones and everything,
but what they're doing is not the original Sphinx.
If you're seeing those people make the sidewalks where it looks like if there's
a bunch of rocks,
but it's not,
it's just a optic or just an illusion where they'd take a,
I like this thing,
they put it down and make like a lines to make it look like rocks and then they
wash it a certain way.
No,
Jamie,
that's,
I'm sorry,
but Jamie's,
that's not real.
Right?
The nose thing.
That's not real.
It looks like they're building a fake nose and his face was like,
what?
No,
so I'm sorry.
So say that again.
They have the,
the,
this,
this way to make uh,
like worried.
If they're making like a sidewalk,
they put down in this,
all this concrete,
then they put like a pattern that looks like a cutout rocks over it and it kind
of like step on it.
They take it off and then they wash like fake wash on it or something.
So then the final product looks like they have individual stones in the sidewalk
when really it's just an illusion.
It's kind of like what,
what it looks like they're doing to the Sphinx where they're almost making it
look like it's like they're putting new rocks in it where it's probably just
lines paint,
airbrush.
Yeah.
It's real weird ma'am.
It's real weird.
You know,
we have ideas about what,
what a,
what a thing is.
And other countries have different ideas like say like,
like uh,
we would look at that and we'd go,
okay,
that's not a restoration.
That shit on the outside is different.
But like in Japan,
like in Japan,
they have buildings like houses that exist that are a thousand years old.
And what they've done is restored everything.
Everything's restored,
all the floorboards are new or the walls or new,
everything's new.
But the shape is the same.
So like we look at it and go,
hey,
that's not the same building.
And they go,
well to them it is cause the them,
it's the original location.
They've restored what it looks like.
And this is the original building to them.
But like in Europe,
like if you go to a pub in London,
you'll go to a pub that's hundreds of years old and that fucking pub is the
same.
You walk down those stairs,
it's all worn out where the people's feet have been.
You look at the walls,
you look at the,
the,
the fucking railings on the bar and it's all worn down.
Look at that place.
Jesus Christ is great.
Fuck.
Where is that gets him absence.
That's in London.
London has some cool old craftsmanship,
man.
I'm gonna go there or been there.
So you never been to London?
I've only been on Canada and Japan.
That's right.
Yeah,
because London will be interesting if you go to,
cause you could do some stand up there.
Yeah,
there's a sweet,
I want to go to Sweden and London.
Do you do,
you would do standup at Sweden.
Yeah,
a lot of Sweden for some reason I just looking at numbers and stuff like that.
Sweden is like with number one almost.
It's the right behind uh,
Canada and Australia.
Well they do speak English.
That's the cool thing about being American.
We're so fucking bad ass.
Other countries speak our language and what I'm saying?
Hmm.
Actually it's like European English thing,
but if you,
uh,
if you go to almost all those countries,
they speak English.
Like I did stand up in Norway or in Sweden rather than I'll Stockholm.
Stockholm.
Yeah.
Is there,
is there a certain countries that you have to know certain rules,
like whatever you do,
it did not talk about [inaudible] now.
Yeah,
I would imagine like in the Middle East especially,
you can't talk shit about the royal family.
Thailand's the same way.
If you talk shit about the king and Thailand,
they'll lock your ass up.
Have you been falling?
What's going on with the black cabs versus Uber?
That's shits.
Interesting.
What's going on?
Uh,
I guess from what I've understand is,
you know,
the guys that you still have the horses back in the days they used to be like,
drive around the course carriages and style and in the UK,
England,
yeah.
Okay.
And then they moved on through cabs and stuff like that.
And I guess Uber's trying to come over there.
And so like,
this is like a family,
you know,
my father used to ride horses and stuff and so they're like pretty much fighting
with the Uber drivers like,
and they're stopping traffic.
Like there's a,
I sent you something that recently,
like the black cabs are protesting or they're just bringing in central London to
a standstill,
uh,
just over this.
Uh,
wow.
This is crazy.
So they just shut down the streets.
Yeah.
And Park their car and shut down the streets.
And the black cab drivers are doing like that.
Kind of like the,
you know,
beating up the Uber drivers and like,
like old school gangs in New York type shit.
But they were just a passed in Vegas.
What?
Yep.
Double.
I got double charged in an la though.
So that's twice as much as la,
but it's still cheaper than a taxi.
You gotta be in a group too or something where,
or five,
six people or something like that?
Well,
I'd really like a cab.
There's some weird rules about it.
Oh,
so they're trying to slowly box him out.
Thinking about it.
Last time I was in Vegas,
it'd be really hard to,
if there's a giant cab line and you're like,
ask her,
I'm going to use an Uber instead.
Yeah.
You just go off to the side of the street like,
and just stop in a caption to pick your right Uber's and a stop on the Strip and
pick you up.
Chaos.
You're right.
Yeah,
that'd be complete chaos.
All would be cars are stopping people getting mad beeping horns.
People are going to shoot people.
It's gonna be crazy.
They'd have to have Uber ports at the hotels or something like that.
That's a crazy picture though.
That London picture.
Put that up again,
Jamie.
Look at that photo.
Look how many calves are are.
They've completely shut the street down.
The,
the folks who are at home,
we're looking@thisondailymail.com.
So you always wonder,
you read something on the Daily Mail.
I kind of full of Shit,
but uh,
the,
the picture is incredible.
They just have all these hundreds and hundreds of cabs shut
down the streets and they're all just sitting around talking.
Well,
you know,
I kind of see where they're coming from.
They don't want to get boxed out by some new a competitor,
but I kind of see where Uber's coming from too.
I took a taxi the other day home from the comedy store on what's usually at $13
cap cabaret.
It costs me $38 30 notice an Uber Guy,
usually it's $13 on Uber usually.
Yes.
And it was $38 on it in a taxi.
13 bucks is super reasonable.
Yeah.
Get you all the way to Burbank from the comedy store.
Yup.
Yeah.
It's nice because if you think about it,
parking is usually 20 bucks.
You pay a little extra,
you can,
don't have to drive,
you don't have to get fucked up and you drive home.
And that,
uh,
that parking lot next door is always a nightmare.
Yeah.
The con the comics,
the uh,
not the sunset strip or other,
it's just,
it's so,
so crowded,
such a crazy place that they're,
when they're,
they've got lost,
get shut down still.
Right now it's open to instruction.
I think it's open now.
It was shut down forever.
Yeah.
Like how many months was it shut down for two maybe while they built something
there.
It's amazing that you can build something.
You could have so much juice that while you're building you can shut down the
whole street in La on sunset.
I mean what?
You have that much juice.
You could shut a street down.
I'm building a house here,
which look,
you stop,
stop driving cars.
Okay.
For how long a couple months was.
If they,
if you said that like I want to build my house here,
but for whatever reason,
because they have more money than you,
they can do that.
Like they're building some stupid ass fucking building that it's more important
they build a stupid ass fucking building than it is for you to drive on the
street that you pay taxes to maintain.
God Damn it,
I'm getting mad.
Or when they,
they're like close down streets for like,
oh they're filming the Kardashians up ahead.
So they had closed down sunset.
That makes me fight for movies too.
They'll shut them down from movies like fuck you.
That's not how it works.
Like,
you don't eat,
you can't just sell the street.
You can't sell.
How much money are you getting?
Where's that money going?
It's inconveniencing all the rest of us.
And you're talking about a place that's already massively overpopulated.
Las extremely overpopulated.
I have friends that work in downtown and uh,
they go to downtown all the time and uh,
they'll tell you like,
it's a two hour drive.
It's a two and a half hour drive.
It's,
it's 30 miles and it'll take you two and a half hours at two in the afternoon,
three in the afternoon.
You might not get there until five.
Like fuck fat.
Like it's,
it's a,
it's a crazy place to live.
We've got a bill.
Where are we going?
Where should we go if we bail or uh,
organisms.
But I'm back to thinking,
uh,
Denver recreational pot becomes legal Thursday.
Woop,
woop,
you back to thinking in Denver.
Here's why.
Like Denver over Oregon,
it doesn't fucking rain every day,
right?
But Hey,
look at that guy.
That's the guy who's been rained on every day since he was three.
He's tired.
His bones are.
He just looks worn out.
They look worn out.
They get worn out.
Yeah.
I think,
I think Denver or even maybe,
I wish Hawaii was swallow.
Portland has some hot chicks.
There's hot girls in Portland.
It's weird.
You wouldn't think they'd be up there this plenty.
Even though it's raining all the time.
I'll probably cry a lot.
You probably cry a lot too.
We'd all cry.
Which call each of the rope.
I don't know man.
I'm thinking to go back to Burma.
The wind.
I could take the rein to see the new Tesla.
Yes.
What do you think?
Why did they have a fucking space door on it?
Why is it a lambo?
Doors?
Cause it's cool man.
Is that why or is it a functional thing?
I don't know.
I think it looks neat.
I Dunno.
See if it's um,
I just want to know why they are there doing that.
That thing,
door thing,
when they're opening the door sideways,
they're opening the doors.
Like the Lamborghini Lamborghini doors.
Like why would you want that?
That doesn't make any sense to me.
It's pretty cool.
Look at him.
He's always got that weird look on his face like,
hmm,
all crime.
You know,
like he's doing something where with his lips like,
alright,
well I'm just going to get all of them all like share
something new BMW ones.
Those look cool.
I liked the look of the,
yeah,
the blue and the white or whatever.
It looks really neat.
It's a tron car.
Some guy in front of me this morning had one.
Those are expensive,
right?
Yeah,
they're really expensive.
They're like 120,000 bucks.
She that's super expensive.
This fucking thing he's got is even more than that.
This fucker's like 140 it's super expensive and it's still bid fast.
It's supposed to go zero to 60 in like three seconds.
It's the battery on this one.
Probably get you around the block a couple times.
Shit's out on you and explode that.
I'm atheist.
I don't know man.
This is what I think about these things.
I love the fact that someone's making them.
I love the fact that they're available.
And if you live in a place like La and you have electrical power or you could
drive this everyday,
plug it in at night,
you'd be fine.
But I would always want to have a real car standing by.
I would always want to have a real car standing by in case the shit hit the fan.
He had to get out of town and you need something that works on just gasoline,
you know,
because I just think if you need to drive a long distance,
like from New York to California,
you can't fucking do it in that thing.
You can't do it.
It goes 250 miles and that's it.
And you got to fucking charge it.
And if you don't charge it,
it's going to leave you somewhere.
But if you're just trying to get around town,
oh it's great.
It's probably the way to go.
Like I should probably get one,
I should probably get a Tesla for like a drive around town car.
It's kind of the pro
get solar power and a Tesla is like the perfect setup for drive around town.
I sent you a send that link of six cars that are taking on Tesla,
know the Porsche mission e which looks pretty sweet.
Awesome.
Lower than a Tesla,
believe it or not.
I think what's cool is the thunder power.
Evie,
have you seen this?
This looks like a Batmobile.
Well,
the prettiest one was the Fisker Karma.
Do you remember the Fisker Karma?
The company went under,
but they created this amazingly beautiful car that even had solar panel on the
roof that powered the radio.
But when they had that big storm and the Pacific North East a few years back,
I left all the Fiskars on the dock and they all got washed away by the ocean and
exploded.
They got the water came out of the ocean and filled up the parking lot in the,
the water level raised up to where the batteries were and they all exploded.
They had like 16.
Whoa.
That's the one I'm talking about.
That's the hold up power eve.
Who made that?
Uh,
it is a Taiwan based maker.
Um,
you know what that looks like.
Like a Nissan Gtr fucked your view.
Your Boat Volkswagen bug.
Yeah,
that's what it looks like.
It goes 62 miles an hour in five seconds.
It's not good as it goes.
A top speed of 155 that can't be right.
62 miles an hour and five seconds.
It's so slow.
Yeah.
That's stupid.
Slow.
That can't be right.
It says,
what does it say that since a reporter accelerate to 62 miles per hour in less
than five seconds?
Yeah,
that's slow as shit,
man.
Like the the modern cars have today.
Like you,
you can get SUVs that do that easy.
Like that's what I think the a range rover does.
I think you'd do a range rover in five seconds.
Those a range rover turbocharged ones,
those are fast as shit,
but like to make a dope look and really flashy in your face car like that.
I think the porch,
I think the Porsche mission e is Martin,
so that looks like a Ford fusion or something to me.
I think it's because they own them.
Oh,
is that why look forward owns acid mark?
Oh yeah.
It's same front as there at Ford fusion or over there.
I'm pretty sure for it owns them.
It doesn't.
Ford owned Jaguar.
Yeah.
Do that.
I think somebody owns Jack who mercury.
No wait,
mercury is mercury real mercury is still thing.
Mercury was the same.
Like it was like the Ford Taurus,
but they just changed the name.
It was so weird.
Who Owns Jaguar?
I'll tell you what Jaguars today are fucking slick.
Yeah.
Like have you uh,
you seen the new one,
the uh,
the new Jaguar coop and Jamie pull out a photo of the new Jaguar coop trying to
find,
continue decide why do they do that?
Yeah.
I'm trying to figure out what am I
do with my car?
Why don't you sell it?
That's what I need to sell it.
Yeah.
That looks sweet.
That is a fucking dope car.
And is that one of those three 60 degree?
Um,
let's see.
Just go to a regular site instead of the,
the car site.
So you can get like some good images of it.
It's a nasty car.
There's super fast to the f type,
I think they call it.
It's like 560 horsepower or something ridiculous really fast.
Really loud like boisterous bomb dude that they nailed it.
Look at that.
Come on.
It's perfect.
Nailed it.
I mean that is a fucking beautiful piece of automotive engineering and artwork.
That is,
they nailed that.
That is a futuristic looking car right there.
It starts off at 63,000.
They're not that expensive for what they are.
I mean for 63,000 you're not going to get the stupid super powerful one,
but you still get that same beautiful shape.
I wonder what their,
um,
maintenance is like cause you know,
car and driver did this thing on the new corvette.
I was like all Gung Ho for the new corvette.
I'm like that car sick.
I think I might,
might be interested in driving one of those go America,
all that good shit.
But their uh,
their repair record at least for car and driver road and track car and driver
one of those years,
I don't know which one it was,
but uh,
their repair record was atrocious.
So like this thing's falling apart.
They had replaced the engine already.
It's 6,000 miles.
They were replacing entire engine.
Maybe we should just eliminate.
They had though.
I had that happen with my old car.
I mean everything went wrong.
Kelly dope.
That cockpit looks like the f Type Interior.
Go full screen on that,
Jamie.
Let me see that.
If you image look at that.
That is fucking,
that's a spaceship man.
God,
I just love what they're doing these days.
I just love the fact that everything continues to improve.
Like whatever you buy,
whether you're,
you're buying toasters or whether you're buying televisions or,
or cars,
they just keep making shit better and better and better.
And now you can get like really good shit.
Fairly reasonably for fair,
fairly reasonable money.
Like I sought some review that we're doing about this new jeep that they have.
It's like a jeep,
but it's based on the Fiat platform.
It's like a tiny jeep,
30,000 bucks.
Really?
Yes.
And you're in it and you know,
you know,
the guy's like looking around,
it's like this is a nice car and it's $30,000.
It's like a small looking smush jeep.
It's,
but you,
you're in it and you know,
looking at like the car,
you like this,
you could get this for 30 grand.
I did is pretty nice.
You know,
it's like you drive it,
it's respectable.
It's a decent vehicle.
Do you think Volkswagen is going to survive this?
They're fucked,
right?
They're fucked.
I better get your money now.
Okay.
Cause I'm trying to figure out what am I do with mine and I,
Dean del Ray's also thinking about buying a Volkswagen and he was there,
he said the other day and they were like convertible.
It's almost like a motorcycle.
Every,
they were talking
about like how,
and this is a rare one and it's just a $3,000 extra bonus for this car.
And I'm like,
wait,
aren't they about to get fucked?
Right?
Like they're doing all right.
I got to get out of it.
Give it to Jean swearing Soto.
He doesn't want him beetle was he want some gangster Gti.
Oh,
type or whatever.
Well those are,
uh,
those are fast little cars.
I used to have Corrado Volkswagon Corrado that was a front wheel drive car.
But those gtis are very fast.
Yeah.
The new ones are ridiculous because as the engineering gets better and the cars
get better,
like even a car that used to be kind of quick,
like back in the day when I had a Volkswagen,
they're fast now.
I'll give you compared like a Volkswagen.
When I had my Volkswagen,
which was 1993 I think I bought it.
The corvette from that day is probably slower than a GTI from today because
they're just better now.
Everything's better.
Breakings better handling.
It's better if it went around.
Uh,
um,
oh slalom.
I bet the GT.
I'd probably beat it.
Yeah,
it goes,
it's the one he's looking at.
It's talk team into that talk to you into your car.
I shouldn't be saying this on launch 292 horsepower.
It's a nice car and it's probably super light.
Two to 92 that's pretty respectable for a light car.
Those are fun man.
Little light,
fun car like that to drive how much those go for a 30 I think.
Why don't you tell those dummies to hook you up?
Say,
listen,
I could just say,
I could just get on a podcast and talk mad shit about you all the time,
but I don't want to do that and say,
ah,
my friend Joe,
he just always wants to talk shit about Volkswagen.
I discourage a lot of the conversations.
But anyway,
that's beside the point.
I'm interested in those.
Gtis can we make something happen?
Golf are whatever it is.
Is that what it is?
A Golf r that's a slick little car.
Yeah,
that's gotta be fun.
I just didn't know whether to stay with Volkswagen or not.
And they're good engineering.
I mean it's German engineering they make,
they've always made great cars.
What they've done is horrible though.
I mean you would have to wonder like whether or not that's reflected in the rest
of what they're doing because that's what they did is terrible.
I mean they've,
they've lied a lot too,
right?
What time is in the Audis too,
I think.
Was it?
I don't think so.
I think I know what you're talking about.
I think Audi was talking about how many different cars it was because they were
a part of the thing.
But I don't believe it was their cars as well.
I'm pretty sure it had to do with diesels for the most part,
which is what Calvin has that fuck.
And I was always telling my,
this thing stinks.
How could this be good for the environment?
Does it smell?
Cause I have my spine,
his old one,
they fucking stink.
And that was always telling him.
I was like,
how can this be good for the environment?
It is.
It's amazing.
It's really good.
It's amazing for the environment.
Yeah.
I mean,
and it's German engineering built in Mexico.
Now.
You know what I would get if I was you,
honestly,
if you don't want to spend too much money,
um,
I would get a Volkswagen,
not
Volkswagen.
I a Mustang get one of the new Mustang thin,
the new Mustang gts.
That's another car that's like 30 [inaudible] and they're really fucking good.
They're really good.
They did a review of one of them recently.
This,
uh,
this guy took it for a test drive and he's driving around and he's like,
this is a hell of a car for 35,000 bucks.
He's like,
it's fast.
It handles good.
It looks great.
Like this is like the bargain of all American cars cause it's like this is the
best Mustang ever by far.
Like by far it's got fully independent suspension.
The,
the,
the form is beautiful.
The interior is really nice.
Like you get in the interior like these fucking seats in the steering wheel.
Like it's a solid car and then you go,
it's only 30 gram like this,
you can get a Mustang gt,
I think it's 35 or $39,000.
And that thing has 420 horsepower fast as shit handles really good.
I mean it's a great car,
but you know,
having such a small fast pepe car the last three years,
it's,
there's a big difference between having like almost like a go cart and then
having like a,
um,
a big muscle car kind of.
Oh like a Mustang mean.
Yeah.
Right.
But there so fast,
you would notice a difference and you'd have,
you'd have more space inside of it.
Like date,
they handle so good.
These new ones,
like they don't feel like big,
you know,
like my Barracuda was a big lumbering fucking shitty to drive cars.
They don't feel like that.
They feel like connected to the road.
Hmm.
Modern Shit man.
They're just so good at it.
They're so good at figuring out suspension.
The dynamics of having like each individual we'll respond to different bumps in
the roads.
Like they have these magnetic ride control suspensions they do in these GM cars
and they're all working on computers and shit and they know when certain wheels
are spinning and certain wheels are dry and they like to understand the terrain.
They have cars that can read the road and prepare for the bumps blocked off.
Fuck.
Like they see the road in front of me like,
oh,
bumps coming.
We'll just going to loosen this up and make this light and,
and tighten this up.
And it's incredible.
Yeah.
There's something missing.
Like when you drive them,
they feel numb.
You know,
like you're not,
you know,
experiencing the feel of the road,
but God,
they're capabilities are just amazing.
Meanwhile,
we're probably 10 years away from having most of the cars on the road automated.
Maybe 10 years away you're going to get in your car in the morning.
Say if you had a regular job,
you would get in your car in the morning and you would press,
you know,
um,
office,
boom,
whatever it is,
and you just sit down,
sit down,
you read a newspaper,
you a look at your laptop and that asshole that's not automated,
he's going to be the problem.
You're like,
I drove to work days just fucking guy and an old Volkswagen.
Totally not automated,
just running red lights.
He hit this lady is automated.
Yeah.
I think that an Uber drones like uh,
you know,
being picked up by a drone is going to be a another thing in the future.
The way more problematic because you're going to have to get something that's
big enough to fly people around in,
which means before Uber ever uses it,
people are going to be flying around in them.
And if once people can fly around in them,
you know,
they're not going to trust other people to drive him around in it.
There'd have to be a way to,
you know what they'd have to do?
They'd have to have those things,
but have them completely magnetized on the outside so they could never collide
with each other.
Yeah.
So there's some something that keeps them from each other and then you would
have to have some,
some software that overrode the ability to direct directed into buildings
because otherwise people would just fucking,
you fucking con,
I'm coming to your work right now.
I'm on the 12th floor.
You now get to the lobby.
Fuck yeah.
And they just fly through the building and killer.
I mean,
the people would do that,
you know,
there'd be people that they just decide fucking,
I'm going to take out the,
the,
the u s open is playing,
I'm going to do the ninth hole and I'm going to fucking crash my car right into
everybody.
People just can decide to go places where ordinarily fences were there until
now.
Have you been tempted to buy a drone yet?
Like I was at Fry's the other day.
They had like a really nice drone,
but you know,
it's like 600 bucks,
but really nice one.
I know a guy who has one.
It was cool.
He brought it to a place where at in Alberta and we were all hanging out in this
field and he sent it up in the air and it's circled us.
It circled us all,
all.
We're all sitting around looking up and it's circled us.
And he showed us the video and I was like,
whoa,
this is nuts.
Like it's high speed HD video from a laptop a or from a,
um,
a cell phone rather.
Like you could,
you could attach like an iPhone to it.
But this is crazy.
Gopros.
Yeah,
it's crazy.
And they're,
they're doing it now where you could see it sets up with virtual reality.
So you put those VR goggles on and then you look through the eyes of the drone.
The drone flies over trees.
I've done that.
That's nuts.
It's weird.
They're big and weddings now,
like that's a huge thing.
Photographers from weddings and ag now have like big drone fly throughs at that
wedding and like that.
What a strange world.
We live in Brighton.
I hereby her the Saudi Prince.
What happened?
You guys got away?
How do you get away?
The guy who was accused of rape and they got it.
They arrested him for bail.
You got a $300,000 bail and now he's gone.
Whoa.
He took off out of the country or city was probably moving.
They saw some cars come in on like Tuesday night,
Wednesday,
Monday night or something like that.
Oh Wow.
Back to Saudi Arabia,
Huh?
Wow.
Saudi royal drama.
The princess flow,
the 37 million dot.
So his bail was 37 million.
This house,
that's how much it's,
oh,
but I heard he was renting.
I heard he was renting the house.
We were just talking about this [inaudible] we like couple of weeks ago when we
were talking about these guys that come over and they have a shit ton of money
and they buy all this expensive real estate,
and then there was the people that were racing.
You saw that,
right,
Brian?
Right.
The racers.
Oh,
he only had $300,000 bail.
Yeah.
How the fuck did I,
they think that that might've been a fucking bullshit La county thing.
They're just taken 300,000 bucks to pay for something and then wow,
he's outta here.
Anyway,
neighbors see that,
believe the prince has already fled the country and a private jet leaving his
rented house behind.
One woman who would only give her name is,
as Isabelle said,
numerous cars were coming in and out of the property late Thursday and it looked
like the prince moving out.
Meanwhile,
another member,
imagine living next to a prince,
another neighbor,
Eric's skin,
Rumpelstiltskin added.
I am sure he has taken off on his private jet by now.
I don't think he even needs a passport to get out of here.
Quote beyond that.
Yeah,
those guys have money.
It's amazing.
The Gary,
this is what you can get away with in 2015 that you only pay a couple hundred
thousand dollars for bail even though they know you're worth trillions and how
much is that guy worth?
And he just bales and there's nothing negative about it.
He's 29 years old,
Huh?
Wow.
It's amazing.
And his name is so confusing.
Hickey.
No one's going to remember it so it can come back here in a couple of weeks.
Well,
he's a
prince dude.
He can't come back.
But unless somehow or another they forget,
Saudi prince accused of sex crimes could face legal lasso in flight.
What?
Legal Lasso just doesn't come back to America when legal lasso,
hey,
don't go there.
They will arrest you.
Okay,
I'll stay here if they let Saudi Arabia gets bombed and that's not going to
happen.
There's so much.
It's really interesting watching periscope over there because they just,
you know,
they want to show off everything they have all the time and it's,
I'll just sit there.
Periscopes really changed me lately.
I'll just sit in bed and just go on the map and go,
let's see who's periscoping in Japan right now.
You know?
Or,
yeah,
and so let's go to Saudi Arabia.
Yeah,
just go to Saudi Arabia.
It's usually a guy just sitting there and like a backseat of a limo.
You know this with like his,
his stuff on and just like,
Hey,
what's up brother?
And they go in between England knowing English.
Like I'll just call them and go,
Yo,
what's up man?
How you doing?
And he's going to talk to you.
Oh Hey.
Yeah.
It's so weird.
They go in between languages.
Oh Wow.
It's very interesting.
So you look,
send a little text message Joan.
Yeah,
I just troll people.
So like I'll start drawing.
I'm like,
where's your tiger?
You guys are rebuilding
when you want,
when you go to their page.
How many people are viewing it?
She's like 10 14 oh wow.
You know,
it's not many people.
You're so weird.
The things that you do,
it's really interesting watching people on periscope with the map feature.
It's really cool cause you could just go,
let's see what's going on.
I random town
in Mexico and it's just some little Mexican woman just sit and go,
you know,
it's weird making tacos and they can talk to us and shit.
Getting the pope to clean her feet.
Yeah.
And there's a lot of weird motivational like speakers and yeah.
And a lot of scam artists guys from in Beverly Hills,
like,
yeah,
I created this company.
If anyone wants to meet here and talk about periscope and,
and he,
you know,
just random women showing up like,
Oh,
you're a millionaire.
I saw you on periscope.
Whoa.
It's creepy.
It is creepy.
Yeah.
I don't use it anymore.
I use it a couple times at the store and I was like,
I can't be fucking bothered.
And also I think there's just sheer,
I've got too much going on as it is.
It's stuff's already spread me thin,
whether it's Facebook or Twitter or Instagram's like,
it's enough.
I go long periods of time without using any of it.
Speaking of which will take an Instagram of you right now,
I'm thinking,
my latest thing is Facebook thinking about get rid of getting rid of Facebook.
What?
I completely,
I mean I just,
okay.
Why would you say you get rid of Facebook?
Uh,
you know when they,
when they do that shit where it's like,
oh,
six years ago today you did this and you're like,
oh my God,
I completely forgot I had that on their smarter part.
Didn't work.
Smile again.
Smile like you're happy.
Not like I can't,
I gotta get my teeth fixed.
What are you doing with your teeth?
Tooth is just,
I have a tooth that was supposed to be replaced 25 years.
Teachers again.
Yeah.
I have a two that was supposed to be fixed like 25 years ago.
It's just a temporary tooth and I haven't fixed it.
And now recently it's just like stained and it won't stop and wold stops.
Deigning now I think I wonder why it's coffee.
Yeah.
Weird.
It's supposed to be,
it's not supposed to be in my mouth though.
They were like,
oh,
you know,
you could wear this for like a couple of months,
but you should come in and probably replace.
This is just a temporary 20 years later guys,
um,
guys,
I hate the dentist.
Why did he do what did,
that's one of the most illogical fears.
The fears of the dentist.
I had a lot of trauma as a kid is in a dentist though,
so it wasn't a happy place for me.
What about that guy that was,
uh,
was he a dentist or a doctor in San Diego?
He raped eight different women.
Eight and they gave him a year of house arrest.
He raped eight different women while they were unconscious.
Put them under and fuck them.
And this guy got a year of house arrest.
Why is that?
Rape Culture a culture?
That's one of the times why I,
aside with the social justice warriors,
I was like,
well,
maybe it's right.
You know,
when you see things like that,
I mean obviously you're dealing with 350 million people in this country.
The number of human beings in this country is fucking staggering.
Okay.
And in that staggering number,
you're going to have cons.
There's absolutely going to be a certain amount of people that are just
horrible.
And this is one of them.
Molest did not fun.
No,
no,
no.
He fucked up.
He fucked them.
He penetrated them when they were unconscious.
I look at him,
he doesn't see my kid.
Very dangerous.
I mean I'm,
I'm not lying.
Right.
Didn't they say he had sex with them?
I'm pretty sure.
Well,
Cosby three new women came out today.
Three new ones.
Yeah.
Jesus.
One victim was only eight years old.
Fuck this guy.
Jesus Christ.
Oh,
there's 12 victims.
Ah,
my God.
He suffers from kidney cancer.
Quickly pleaded guilty,
sparing his victims for testifying about his crimes.
I don't want to hear this man.
I want this guy to just be dead.
Fuck yeah.
That's the idea that someone could do that to you while your unconscious just
fuck you.
Such one of the creepiest things.
Managing like standing over someone,
whether unconscious and just thinking about what you're gonna do to them and
looking them in the head.
Pull your dick out and rescue on their nose.
Taking pictures.
Yeah.
I had that once and it freaked me out.
I woke up in another room.
It was dark and like,
wait,
where am I?
And I totally forgot where I was counting backwards.
Did you really?
Yeah.
Like you thought you were unconscious?
No.
Like,
like what do you mean where they make it count backwards and then you wake up
and you're in another room,
you're like,
wait,
what the fuck happened?
Where am I?
So what is,
what is your fear about the dentist?
Like did you,
did you experience pain when you were a kid?
Yeah,
when I was young I was in a car accident and my teeth,
my two front teeth got knocked in half.
They cut in half in this car accident and I had to have a lot of different
surgeries and,
and I mean I'm like six years old getting drills and shit in my mouth.
Uh,
and then I've had them knocked out before right after that and they put them in
again.
Just like the,
my growing up,
I had a lot of teeth problems,
just like surgical stuff and like two separate wisdom tooth compact tooth
implant into my skull.
It's crazy.
Teeth are kind of annoying.
You got to stop thinking about it.
You only get one pair of them.
They're not even anchored in.
And they would come out,
yeah,
punched a fallout and then they're gone forever.
Like what?
Like I've seen a lot of people get their teeth knocked out.
Super common in MMA.
It happens all the time.
It happens in fights all the time while I'll be talking to the guys even post
fight and they're like,
my feet teeth are knocked out,
my teeth are like really loose right now.
Like you see the blood and they have to go and get everything wired in.
It's real common.
So shitty design.
Yeah.
Well nowadays with implants and uh,
you know there's fake teeth.
Everyone has really nice teeth.
Stem cell dental implants grow new teeth right in your mouth that Jesus Christ
is from 2010 but I heard about recently,
it still sounds pretty cool,
especially as the stem cell stuff you've been talking about.
Dude,
I am a big fan.
I need a stem cell.
My knee,
you probably do,
I'm a big
fan of the stem cells.
I wouldn't say my,
excuse me,
I wouldn't say that my shoulder is 100% after stem cell because I still kind of
feel it but I don't have any pain and I'm not,
I'm not doing anything heavy as far as like bench pressing.
But I'm doing a lot of crazy rowing like heavyweights,
like hundred pound dumbbells,
hundred 10 pound dumbbells.
No problem.
I'm doing chin ups.
I'm doing hard sets of Chin ups.
You know,
like,
like we're,
we're,
I'm pulling to fatigue.
No problem.
I'm doing push.
I've,
I haven't done any bench press but I've been doing like a lot of sets of pushups
cause I don't want to tax the area too much cause it's only been two months.
I keep waiting for it to hurt the next day.
No problems,
no pain.
One fucking injection of stem cells.
Wow.
And it seems like every day like the east to like click and crunch a lot
everyday the clicking crunching gets lighter and lighter.
It's like it's less and less.
It's only been eight weeks.
It'd be eight weeks on Friday.
That's great.
It's nuts.
It's nuts man.
It's weird.
Can you just go get another one or do you have to wait a certain amount of time
before that's debatable?
You know,
it depends on who you're talking to.
Like Dr. Gordon says,
I can do it all the time.
He's like,
go in again.
it's just healing you.
He's like,
they're just,
what it is is just the stem cells will find the area of your body that's having
an issue and they go in and heal it.
But the,
the other doctors are more cautious.
They were like,
you know,
but he's dealing with football players at brain injuries and soldier's brain
injuries and fighters have brain injuries.
So he's like,
what are you pussy?
You got something wrong.
Your shoulders shoot it up.
Do they know what happens if there's,
if they inject too much of a dick rose,
huge grows a second head and they fight to the death,
the first head and the second and fight to the death,
then you have to kill the dead head.
You have to get a chopped off.
But if you put stem cells and sperm and then it makes it put it in stem cells
protests different,
you probably wouldn't enjoy it.
My,
uh,
my friend who works at to hone ranch,
my friend Brian sent me a photograph when people get mad at people that hunt and
need to understand that one of the biggest things that kills animals like deer
and elk is they kill each other.
This big giant elk got killed by another elk.
It stabbed him to death with its antlers.
Like the size of that fucker.
It's huge.
Huge.
It looks like it has a one,
two,
three,
four,
five,
six,
seven,
eight points on one side and seven points on another.
So it's an enormous,
enormous elk and another elk stabbed to death with its antlers and they found it
rotten with holes in its sides.
It's nuts.
Damn right now,
10 killed up to 10 killed and shooter in Oregon College Right now,
today,
right now.
Fuck 20 injured Jesus.
Shoot her up and fired.
You know what?
If they had guns on schools,
here's what's fucked up.
That wouldn't happen if people allowed to have guns on campus.
If there were armed guards on campus,
if teachers were allowed to carry guns,
if students were allowed to carry guns,
if the gun enthusiasts,
like everybody's worried,
the gun enthusiasts would be shooting more people.
I don't think that's the problem.
I think if people want to shoot people,
they can get guns pretty easy like this guy,
but I think regular people,
if they had guns more often,
this is a very controversial stance because a lot of people think that more guns
is more problems,
but I think that a lot of reasons why these people that are horrible,
horrible people that go in to these things and shoot up schools is because they
know schools are not going to be armed to same reason why they don't want to go
and shoot up a military base unless they're trying to suicide.
You know?
You mean like security guards are like security guards as teachers.
I think teachers should be able to have guns and there's police and a lot of
community.
I had an a nibble.
There's police had a lot of colleges.
Some colleges,
but this was a community college,
so I would imagine they didn't.
Yeah,
I just,
and you know how,
how,
uh,
armed are they,
you know,
how,
uh,
how well prepared are they for something like this?
It's terrible,
man.
This fucking shit drives me nuts.
It just,
and again,
if you look at the numbers,
like everybody's like terrified.
And when things,
things like this happen,
people call for gun control.
And I totally understand that way of thinking.
I understand that you're saying,
hey,
the problem is the guns.
We have to take the guns away from all these people.
We definitely have to keep guns out of the hands of irresponsible people.
We definitely have to keep guns out of the hands of insane people.
Definitely.
That's 100%.
But the idea that somehow or another crazy person doing something bad should
prevent a rational,
sane person from having a gun.
That doesn't make any sense to me.
It just doesn't make any sense.
It's not logical thinking.
The problem isn't guns.
The problem is insane people.
And if they didn't have guns but they had bombs,
you don't think they'd be setting bombs off all over the school.
So what are we gonna do?
We're gonna get rid of explosives and then we're going to get rid of sharp
objects.
We're going to get rid of everything.
People are the problem people.
Their access to weapons is certainly a problem when they're nuts.
But the real problem is that they're nuts.
The vast majority of people that I know that own guns,
and this is where it gets crazy,
this is the truth.
When I go to the gun range,
they are some of the nicest,
most polite fucking people.
The people that I know from the world of hunting,
some of the nicest,
most polite people,
they're,
they're really friendly folks.
They,
they're not bad people.
Like this idea that you're going to keep some psychopath from guns by taking the
guns away from everybody.
Like that's not,
that's not smart thinking.
We have to figure out why the fuck people want shoot people.
We have to figure out what the hell makes someone want to go to a school and
start opening fire.
And killing a bunch of students.
That's what we have to figure out cause they are the problem.
It's not the,
the actual weapon that they're using.
It's not the problem.
It's the actions of the human being and their mind.
It's fucked.
You know people are here until you get away my guns,
but why are you taking away their guns?
They didn't shoot anybody like it's not,
it's they're not the problem.
The problem is the people that would be willing to do something like this snack.
Keeping the actual,
the actual objects away from people.
It's keeping figuring out what the fuck makes people want to use those objects.
You don't have a gun now and now?
Not Real one.
I have a lot of fake ones.
Oh that's good.
What do you do with them is to have your ass play cops and robbers.
I'm losing again.
Shit.
Don't rate me with his gun.
[inaudible] can't believe you're doing it again.
Pretty much.
Why do you fake guns?
I get real.
I need to get a real guy.
I mean I have no problem having a gun.
I just,
I only have fake guns because it was for a costume,
but,
oh,
okay.
It's not like I'm trying to really,
well,
you shot a real rifles with me.
We made a video.
It was fun.
I got to go next week.
If you want to go.
Yeah,
I'd love to go.
Okay.
Probably gonna wind up going Monday or Tuesday.
I'll let you know.
Cool.
It's fun.
It is fun.
As long as you have proper ear protection,
it's fun to make sure it goes fun to shoot those hard drives.
That was fun.
Yeah.
Cause it's a small target.
You got to really concentrate.
Yeah,
I might have it.
We should try to bring some other cool stuff to shoot.
So yeah,
they don't want us to though.
Creates a mess,
you know,
we didn't even ask.
We just brought him out there.
We're kind of sneaky about it.
Blew those hard drives to shit though.
It's kind of fun.
It's uh,
it's fun to shoot things.
Like,
people don't like to admit that for whatever reason.
But it's fun.
Interesting for guns are fun.
Interesting thing about the new iPhone,
I found out that they actually have water seals inside of it.
Like,
did you see that video?
This woman put her phone in air for like a,
I think it was like an hour or something like that.
Underwater.
No problem.
Still worked and everything works.
The,
the,
the power port works.
Everything works.
Yeah,
they tore it down.
They found there,
there's a rubber washers around to almost everything now that it didn't used to
be there.
And the reason why they're saying that is because apple has that new a trade in
program.
Every year we can upgrade to a new phone.
And so now there's going to be so many people returning their phones.
They don't want to have a bunch of ruin phones,
you know,
so it's up to them.
Oh thanks apple for,
I haven't gotten a new one yet.
Did you get new and yet,
uh,
it's,
it's back right now,
but yeah,
I'm on that program where you can get a new phone every year.
So backward already.
Yeah,
it was back ordered immediately.
So when you go to the apple store,
they're back ordered.
Yeah.
Sons of bitches.
13 million or something in the first couple of days.
Yeah.
People love them.
You know when Lewis was here from unbox therapy,
I'm telling you that that active galaxy that he left,
I think I liked that better than all of them.
The fact that it's waterproof has that shock resistant case.
Really a really tough screen.
I liked that one the best.
It makes sense.
Yeah.
Why does an apple macbook an apple sport,
you know a make a phone like that.
Like a little bit smaller screen,
like super rugged.
Make it super waterproof.
Hard on the outside camp.
Rake it.
Make that make a man.
It's fun Bro.
I gotta get Outta here.
Sorry.
1215 I got shit.
I got to do anything else going on.
I'll be in Fresno tomorrow is Sam Aaa.
Oh,
that sounds like a day and night trip drive home son.
Yeah,
but we,
they just added a second show.
I'm going to be at the club one casino.
You can I go to tickets.
I just go to a desk.
squad.tv and click on tour dates.
Powerful.
See,
I'm Tripoli.
I ran into him last night.
He was telling me that he's a,
he's auditioning for the tonight show.
He's got something going on.
Oh,
really?
Yeah.
It would be awesome to see Sam do four minutes on the tonight show because you
do like four,
four and a half minutes.
But they're,
uh,
they're having comics on.
That's interesting.
Yeah.
That's in New York.
They asked me to do it.
What?
I don't think I can do it.
I don't think I could do a four and a half minutes set.
I wouldn't,
I wouldn't even know what to talk about.
Like I don't have that kind of an act one story.
Even then it would be like,
God,
I would have to really know how to get out of the gate fast to do four and a
half minutes.
We have fun writing exercises if I was motivated,
but
a Fresno.
So desk squad.
Dot TV for that.
Yeah.
Every Wednesday.
Next Wednesday comedy store have a secret show.
Oh,
and next Wednesday to see it was a secret.
What you just told everybody.
Your secret guest.
Oh,
secret gas shot.
Six getting out.
All right,
folks,
that's it for this week.
You got four podcasts.
Why are you complaining?
You fucks.
You got two,
two and a,
a bonus three and a bonus.
Um,
but we'll be back next week.
Lots of,
uh,
exciting.
Get Alonzo boat and we'll be here next week too.
Very excited.
I love Alonzo having done a podcast with me.
Yeah,
I can't believe it.
Uh,
and that's,
it's so a,
enjoy your weekend.
Go Fuck Yourself.
Here's does a kiss for you.
Here's the one for your mom.
All right.
Much love.
See you soon.
Bye.